THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK.
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ACOSTA
AGUIAR CURRY.
ALLEN
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BROUGH.
BURKE
CABALLERO CALDERON CARILLO
SERVAN TAZ
CHAU CHAVEZ CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY.
COOPER CUNNINGHAM.
DALLEY. DAILY.
EGGMAN FLORA FONG.
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON. GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GRAY. GRAYSON HARPER HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LIMON.
LOW. MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS
MAYES
MCCARTY. MEDINA MELENDEZ
MULLIN MASUCCI NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA. REYES RODRIGUEZ
RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH
STONE.
THURMOND.
TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER.
WOULD.
YOU SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AND
IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
DAYS PRAYER. WILL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND BOB OSHITA.
RIVER NOTION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
NOT LONG AGO. I SAW A
DOCUMENTARY ON SOME OF THE
OLDEST KEY PART IN THE WORLD.
ANCIENT CAVE PAINTINGS HAVE BEEN
FOUND IN VARIOUS PLACES IN THE
WORLD AND DATE BACK. MORE THAN
THIRTY FIVE TO FORTY THOUSAND
YEARS.
WHAT I FOR WHAT I FOUND THOUGHT
PROVOKING WITH A BOLD CLEAR VET
COLORED HANDPRINTS
DISCOVERED ON THE WALLS OF THE
EL CASTILLO CAVED IN SPAIN?
THE MANY PAIRS OF HANDPRINTS
WERE MADE BY ICY MEN WOMEN AND
CHILDREN.
I CAN IMAGINE THAT WHEN THESE
PREHISTORIC HANDPRINTS WERE
FIRST DISCOVERED.
THE PEOPLE THAT STUMBLE UPON
THEM INSTINCTIVELY REACHED OUT
TO PLACE THEIR HANDS OVER THEM.
MATCHING FINGERS TO FINGERS AND
PALMS TWO POEMS.
THIS I FEEL. REFLECT A NATURAL
WISH TO CONNECT WITH OUR HUMAN
ANCESTORS
WHO LIVED OVER THIRTY TO FORTY
THOUSAND YEARS AGO.
WITH THAT TOUCH
WE CONNECT WITH OUR SHARED
HUMANITY ACROSS TIME.
THEY WISH TO CONNECT WITH OUR
HUMAN FAMILY LIES DEEP WITHIN
US.
LET US TRY TO IGNITE THAT
NATURAL WISH TO CONNECT. WITH
OUR SHARED HUMANITY NOT JUST THE
COST TIME. BUT ALSO IN THE HERE
AND NOW.
NO MORE MEET UP.
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WHERE.
THANK YOU REVEREND. WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING. AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE. AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE MISTER LIVING.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY JANUARY
EIGHTEENTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
SEMI MET AT NINE A. M. ON A
LAURA FRIEDMAN ASSISTANT SPEAKER
PRO TEM OF THE ASSEMBLY
PRESIDING CHIEF CLERK
DOTSON WILSON AT THE DESK.
HINKLER KATHY AND LUIS READING
THE ROLL WAS CALLED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA MOVED A
QUORUM CALL THE ASSEMBLY MOTION
CARRY TIME AND A BY MISTER
CALDERON MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS AT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL WILL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ.
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS.
AND RESOLUTIONS.
THE ABSENCES FOR THE DAY THERE
ARE.
NO EXCUSED ABSENCES TODAY
.
WE ARE MOVING TO PROCEDURAL
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW TO HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
SOME MEMBERS BLAKE BAKER. BLOOM
AND RESEARCH YOU TO SPEAK ON AND
GERMAN IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER SB TWENTY FIVE
PORTANTINO FROM THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER AND AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR I AM
GIVING A ONE DAY NOTICE OF
INTENT TO REMOVE ITEM A EIGHT.
S. B. FIVE ANYONE DALY ON FROM
THE.
A CLERK WILL NOTE
MEMBERS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
SPECIAL GUEST WITH US IN THE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER TODAY.
YOU PLEASE WOULD GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO YOUR COLLEAGUES
.
MR LOW.
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE GUESTS WITH
US IN THE CHAMBER IF YOU'RE
READY SIR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GAS INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS UP PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING A CAR
GUARDINO AND THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBERS HE IS CURRENTLY THE.
CEO OF THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP HE SERVED WITH
DISTINGUISHED HONOR ON THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. IS ALSO A MEMBER OF
OUR FAMILY AS YOU IN HIS PAST
LIFE WAS ALSO LEGISLATIVE
STAFFERS SO WOULD YOU PLEASE
JOIN ME IN GIVING A WELL. A
WELCOME ROUND OF APPLAUSE AND
WELCOME TO CARL GUARDINO
AS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL GAS WITH
US IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY.
YOUR HOLDEN.
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE GUESTS WITH
US YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I DO I
WOULD LIKE TO. ON BEHALF OF THE
LEGISLATURE INVITE.
AND WELCOME THE INDIVIDUALS FROM
THE PASS IN CITY COLLEGE BOARD
OF TRUSTEES AND ASSOCIATE
STUDENTS. OTHER JUST OVER MY.
A SHOULDER HERE.
LET ME RECOGNIZE JIM AUSTER
LINK TRUSTEE.
ROSS SELVAGE.
TRUSTEE LINDA WAH. TRUSTEE.
EMILY EXITING EXXON.
TRUST STUDENT TRUSTEE.
ADRIAN CASILLAS.
ASSOCIATE STUDENTS SUPREME
COUNCIL CHIEF JUSTICE.
AND GABY GROW.
ASSOCIATED STUDENT.
LOBBY COMMITTEE CHAIR PLEASE
WELCOME ARM.
REPRESENTS HER PASADENA CITY
COLLEGE BOARD OF TRUSTEES.
AND MR STONE YOU HAVE GUESTS
TODAY.
HIM MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
IF YOU LOOK UP IN THE GALLAGHER
UP TO THE RIGHT.
IS BROKE OUT TRUE SIX OH FIVE TO
SEVEN FROM SAN JOSE THEIR HERE
TODAY. WORKING ON A GOVERNMENT
MERRICK BADS
YOU COULD ALL STAND UP AND BE
RECOGNIZED GIVE THEM A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE AND WARM UP
AND MS CABALLERO.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION WAS CABALLERO. WHO HAS
GUESTS WITH US IN CHAMBER TODAY?
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
LATINO CAUCUS.
INTRODUCED MISTER TIM AT NINE
THIS.
AND THE FAMILY MEMBERS OF FOR
VICTIMS OF A TRANCE TRAGIC PLANE
CRASH.
THAT OCCURRED SEVENTY YEARS AGO
NEAR THE TOWN OF KALINGA IN
FRESNO COUNTY.
THIS TRAGIC TRAGIC INCIDENT
OCCURRED ON JANUARY TWENTY
EIGHTH NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT AND
TOOK THE LIVES OF THIRTY TWO
INDIVIDUALS.
TWENTY EIGHT MEXICAN CITIZENS
WHO WERE BEING DEPORTED.
AND FOR AMERICAN CREW MEMBERS.
AT THE TIME IT WAS THE WORST
AIRPLANE DISASTER IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY.
WHILE THE NAMES OF THE AMERICAN
CREW MEMBERS WERE IMMEDIATELY
RELEASED.
THE MEXICAN PASSENGERS WERE
SIMPLY LISTED AS DEPORTEES.
AND REMAINED ANONYMOUS FOR SEVEN
DECADES.
TO ADD INSULT TO INJURY THE
REMAINS OF THE MEXICAN
PASSENGERS WERE BURIED IN A
LARGE MASS GRAVE IN FRESNO'S
HOLY CROSS CEMETERY. LISTING
THEM ONLY AS NUMBERS ONE THROUGH
TWENTY EIGHT.
AND THE WORDS MEXICAN NATIONAL.
THEIR IDENTITIES REMAINED
ANONYMOUS UNTIL TWO THOUSAND AND
TEN.
WHEN AWARD WINNING AUTHOR TIM
AND I'M DOES THE SON OF MIGRANT
WORKERS.
MIGRANT FARM WORKERS AND
PROFESSOR AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
TEXAS EL PASO EMBARKED ON A SIX
YEAR SEARCH TO IDENTIFY THE
VICTIMS LOCATE THEIR FAMILIES
AND WRITE THEIR STORIES IN HIS
BOOK.
ALL THEY WILL CALL YOU.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
MANY OF THE PLANE CRASH VICTIMS
WERE WELCOMED TO THE U. S. AS
PART OF THE BRACERO PROGRAM
WHERE THEY HELPED FILL. A LABOR
SHORTAGE DURING WORLD WAR TWO.
THE VICTIMS AND MANY IMMIGRANT
FARMER FARMWORKERS LIKE THEM
PLAYED A CRITICAL.
A ROLE IN THE WAR EFFORT. THEIR
WORK PROVIDED FOOD FOR OUR
FAMILIES AT A TIME OF NEED AND
WHEN THE WAR WAS OVER THEY WERE
SHIPPED BACK HOME TO THEIR HOME
COUNTRY.
I'M HONORED TO BE ABLE TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THIS
TRAGIC EVENT AND ELECT THEIR
FAMILIES KNOW THAT THEIR LOVED
ONES ARE REMEMBERED. AND VALUED
AS PART OF THE HISTORY OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND FOR
THEIR CONTRIBUTION TO OUR
COUNTRY. DURING WARTIME.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
MISTER KIM AT NINE DAYS AND THE
RELATIVES OF POOR FOR OF THE
PLANE CRASH VICTIMS WHAT THE NEW
BED AYE METIS LADA. I'M ON
FRIDAY THIS GONZALEZ THE MUST
MARKETS BY THE HOUR IN FRANCISCO
AND NONE THERE'S GOOD I'M YAMAS.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO MEET MISTER
HERNANDEZ OR THE FAMILY MEMBERS
IT WILL BE IN ROOM TWO ELEVEN
FROM NOW UNTIL THE SENATE BEGINS
A FOR CEREMONY DURING THEIR
SESSION TODAY.
THANK YOU WELCOME. AND WE HONOR
THE SERVICE AND
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
FILE ITEMS ONE THROUGH FOUR WILL
BE CONTINUED
.
MEMBERS WE ARE.
GOING TO MOVE TO SENATE THIRD
READING.
WE'RE GOING TO START ON SENATE
THIRD READING.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS A RETAIN.
ON FILE ITEMS FORTY THROUGH
FORTY TWO.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FORTY FOUR.
IN THIS IS.
S. C. A..
NUMBER NINE.
THIS IS S. C. A. NINE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SENATE CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT
NINE BY SENATOR GLAZER AND ACT
LIKE THE TAXATION.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THINK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON.
MISTER SPEAKER SCA NINE IF
APPROVED BY THE VOTERS WOULD
GIVE THE LEGISLATURE THE POWER
TO ALLOW PROPERTY OWNERS TO
INSTALL RAIN WATER CAPTURE
SYSTEMS WITHOUT TRIGGERING A
REASSESSMENT OF THE VALUE OF
THEIR PROPERTY. IN AN INCREASE
IN THEIR PROPERTY TAXES
THIS EXCLUSION IS SIMILAR TO THE
ONES CREATED FOR SOLAR PANELS IN
THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES.
RAIN WATER CAPTURE SYSTEMS ARE
CRITICAL TOOL IN ADAPTING TO THE
NEW REALITY A PERSISTENT AND
INTENSE DROUGHT.
THE SYSTEMS ARE CRUCIAL FOR
WATER CONSERVATION EFFORTS BY
COLLECTING AND STORING RAINWATER
WHEN AVAILABLE IN FREEING UP
CONVENTIONAL SOURCES FOR OTHERS.
BY INCENTIVIZING BOTH HOMEOWNERS
AND DEVELOPERS TO BUILD THE
SYSTEMS WE ARE FURTHER EXPANDING
OUR STATES WATER CONSERVATION
EFFORTS.
THIS BILL ALONG WITH THE
COMPANION BILL S. B. FIVE.
.
FIVE EIGHT.
HAS RECEIVED WIDE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK. THANK YOU WAS GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
ON THE AMENDMENT.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS IS REQUIRES A TWO THIRDS
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS THEIR HOME.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE TIED ABOUT AYE AYES
SIXTY NINE.
NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM FORTY THREE.
THAT IS S. B. FIVE FIVE EIGHT.
CORKERY.
SENATE BILL FIVE FIFTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR GLAZIER ACTUALLY
TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
IS GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU MAY
AGAIN OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AS I
JUST MENTIONED EARLIER
PRESENTATION OF AS CA NINE THIS
BILL IS NECESSARY TO PROPERLY
IMPLEMENT THAT. INITIATIVE IF IT
IS PASSED THAT YOU'D IF IT IS A
PASSED BY AS.
THE VOTERS
AND THIS BILL ALSO RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIVEAU.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
QUIRK LIBERAL. ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERSVOTE THE DESIRE TO
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLL AND TELL YOU THAT I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES AND AGAIN WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SENATE
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE UP.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
EIGHT ON ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
THAT IS A C. R. ONE FORTY SEVEN.
THE CORPORATE.
AS ON THE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FORTY SEVEN BY SOME A MEMBER
KALRA AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
INDIA REPUBLIC DAY.
MISTER KALRA ON THE RESOLUTION.
THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ACR ONE
FORTY SEVEN AND RECOGNITION OF
INDIA REPUBLIC DAY.
AS THE VERY FIRST INDIAN
AMERICAN IS SERVING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE. IT
IS TRULY AN HONOR FOR ME TO
SHARE WITH YOU ONE OF THE MOST
CELEBRATED NATIONAL HOLIDAYS OF
INDIA. AND PRESENT IT HERE IN
OFFICIAL CAPACITY.
AND TO ALSO SPEAK ON BEHALF THE
API CAUCUS IN THEIR SUPPORT OF
INDIA REPUBLIC DAY.
ALTHOUGH INDIA PROCLAIMS
INDEPENDENCE ON AUGUST FIFTEENTH
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN BALLING THE
ICONIC MOVING OF DIALOGUE
VIOLENT RESISTANCE OF CIVIL
DISOBEDIENCE. LED BY MAHATMA
GANDHI IT NOT YET HAVE A
PERMANENT CONSTITUTION.
THE CONSTITUTION THAT WAS
ADOPTED IN NINETEEN FIFTY AND
CELEBRATED EVERY YEAR ON JANUARY
TWENTY SIX.
GAVE THE CITIZENS OF INDIA THE
POWER TO CHOOSE THEIR OWN
GOVERNMENT.
AND PAVE THE WAY FOR DEMOCRACY.
WITH A POPULATION OF MORE THAN
ONE POINT TWO BILLION PEOPLE
OVER EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION OF
WHOM ARE ELIGIBLE TO VOTE.
THE REPUBLIC OF INDIA IS THE
WORLD'S LARGEST DEMOCRACY AND
SHARES COMMITMENT TO THE BASIC
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES OF
FREEDOM. OPPORTUNITY AND
JUSTICE.
AS ONE OF THE THREE NATIONAL
HOLIDAYS IN INDIA REPUBLIC DAY
HONORS THE COUNTRY'S RICH
HISTORY VIBRANT CULTURE AND
DIVERSE HERITAGE.
THIS RESOLUTION OFFERS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REFLECT ON THE
MANY ACHIEVEMENTS OF THE INDIAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS HOME TO THE
LARGEST POPULATION OF ANY
AMERICANS IN THE UNITED STATES.
TODAY PEOPLE OF INDIAN HERITAGE
HAVE AND CONTINUE TO MAKE
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTIONS TO
AMERICAN CULTURE.
ANY AMERICANS HAVE BUILT
DEFENDED AND EMPOWERED OUR
COUNTRY AS AGRICULTURAL LABORERS
AS SERVICE MEMBERS THE MILITARY
AS ENTREPRENEURS SCIENTISTS
ARTISTS ACTIVISTS AND LEADERS OF
OUR NATION'S GOVERNMENT.
AS THE WORLD'S OLDEST DEMOCRACY.
AND THE WORLD'S LARGEST
DEMOCRACY RESPECTIVELY.
THE UNITED STATES AND INDIA
SHARE COMMON VALUES AND THESE
TIES HAVE FOSTER GROWTH IN BOTH
COUNTRIES.
REPUBLIC DAYS SERVICE REMIND US
OF THE FOUNDATION OF ANY NATION
AND OUR STATE IS IN ITS PEOPLE.
IN THEIR SPIRIT AND COURAGE IN
THE FACE OF ADVERSITY AND AND
THEIR WILLINGNESS TO SACRIFICE
IN THE PURSUIT OF FREEDOM AND
LIBERTY.
IT IS NOT JUST A CALL FOR
FREEDOM THAT WE CELEBRATE.
THE CONSTITUTION WHICH
GUARANTEES FREEDOM AND BRINGS IT
TO LIFE.
IT IS MY PRIVILEGE TO PRESENT
ACR ONE FORTY SEVEN IN HONOR OF
INDIA REPUBLIC DAY WITH HOPE TO
FOR THE DIVERSITY. OF OUR
COMMUNITY AND AFFORD ALL
CALIFORNIA'S OPPORTUNITY TO
RECOGNIZE AND CELEBRATE INDEED
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES BASS
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR GREAT STATE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA MISTER
COOPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF ACR ONE FORTY
SEVEN. IN THE REPUBLIC DAY THIS
DAY CELEBRATES THE START OF THE
LARGEST DEMOCRACY IN THE WORLD.
IS IMPORTANT THAT WE RECOGNIZE
THE CONTRIBUTIONS.
PEOPLE OF ALL BACKGROUNDS HEAD
TO THE INDIAN REPUBLIC.
MY DISTRICT IS A LARGE HINDU
SEEK.
THE MUSLIM INDIAN POPULATIONS.
MANY OF THESE GROUPS FOR THE
FOUNDATION TO CREATE OF CREATING
THE IN THE REPUBLIC.
IT'S A PROUD COAUTHOR OF THIS
MEASURE ARE STRICTLY ASKS FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
NAMES COOPER.
MS GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ACR ONE FORTY SEVEN.
PROCLAIMING JERRY TWENTY SIXTY
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN F. IN REPUBLIC
DAY. AND IT'S ALL CALIFORNIANS
WHO JOINED IN CELEBRATING THE IN
THE REPUBLIC PAIN.
IN MY DISTRICT THAT HAVE THE
PLEASURE OF REPRESENTING LITTLE
INDIA THE CITY OF ARTESIA.
THIS WEEKEND I HAD THE PLEASURE
OF CELEBRATING IN THE REPUBLIC
BE WITH THE FEDERATION OF INDIAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES. ACROSS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RIGHT THANK
THEM FOR ALL THE WAY TO
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS TO OUR
SOCIETY AND CULTURE OF
CALIFORNIANS AND AS AMERICANS.
TODAY WE COMMEMORATE THE
STRUGGLES THAT THE PEOPLE OF
INDIA AND DIRT IN ORDER TO GAIN
THE ABILITY TO GOVERN
THEMSELVES.
TO THE SIDE THEIR OWN FAITH.
TO HAVE LAWS ON A GOVERNMENT
THAT REFLECTS THE PEOPLE OF
INDIA.
THE RIGHT TO HAVE A GOVERNMENT
OF THE PEOPLE BY THE PEOPLE IS A
BELIEF THAT THE PEOPLE OF BOTH
INDIA. AND THEN THAT IN THE
UNITED STATES UNDERSTAND ALL TOO
WELL.
AND AT THE CHAIR OF THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS I'M COMPELLED TO MENTION
INDIA'S FIRST FEMALE PRIME
MINISTER BACK IN NINETEEN SIXTY
SIX. WENT IN THERE ARE GONE THE.
DEMOCRACY IS THE NEVER ENDING
JOURNEY THAT WE CARS ALL OF US
TO KEEP WORKING AT IT AND TO
KEEP MOVING FORWARD.
AS WE KEEP FORWARDING AS WE KEEP
MOVING FORWARD AS A NATION AND A
STATE I HOPE TO SEE FEMALE
BILLION OR TOP LEADERSHIP ROLES
WITHIN. MY LIFETIME.
IT ALSO REMINDS US OF HOW TO
LEVERAGE WE ARE HEARING
CALIFORNIA. EVERY CELEBRATION OF
ARE THEY VIRTUALLY BUILT LIKE AN
ACTIVE ASSISTANCE AND IT GIVES
ME HOPE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
NAME IS GARCIA MISTER HOLDEN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF ACR ONE FORTY
SEVEN.
JANUARY TWENTY SIX TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THAT MARKS THE SIXTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE DAY THE
CONSTITUTION OF INDIA TOOK A
FACT.
JUST LIKE THE UNITED STATES
INDIA OBTAINED ITS INDEPENDENCE
FROM BRITISH RULE.
AND JUST LIKE THE UNITED STATES
INDIA ENJOYS A DIVERSE
COURAGEOUS PUBLIC.
BRAVELY SACRIFICE FOR FREEDOM
AND LIBERTY.
FROM FOOD TO MEDICINE FROM
SCIENCE TO OUR.
ASIAN INDIANS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
SUBSTANTIALLY INFLUENCE THIS
GREAT STATE.
INDIA REPUBLIC DAY ACKNOWLEDGES
THE GREAT IMPACT THAT INDIA HAS
ON THE WORLD AND THE EXCEPTIONAL
IMPACTED INDIAN AMERICANS HAVE
ON CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN.
MISTER COOLEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I'M VERY HONORED TO
RISE ON THIS OCCASION AS WE
CELEBRATE REPUBLIC DAY FOR THE
GREAT NATION OF INDIA.
THAT GREAT DEMOCRATIC NATION.
AND IT'S IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
DAY. IN THE LIVES OF MANY OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS.
BUT A VERY SINGULAR DATE FOR ALL
OF US IN THIS CHAMBERS TO
REFLECT UPON.
THERE WAS A COURSE OF TIME.
A LONG TIME WHEN THEY WERE NOT
GOVERNING THEMSELVES.
THERE ARE SUBJECT TO BRITISH
RULE.
THEY BECAME AN INDEPENDENT
NATION.
AND I THINK THE LESSON IS
RELEVANT TO US IN OUR OWN WORK.
WE GRAPPLE WITH MANY ISSUES IN
OUR LIVES.
MANY ISSUES THAT SEEM LIKE.
THE STATUS QUO WILL NEVER
CHANGE.
AM.
INDIA REPRESENTS IN REPUBLIC DAY
REPRESENTS THAT EVOLUTION THEN
THAT MUST BE AT THE HEART OF
DEMOCRACY TO CONTINUALLY.
RENEW ITSELF.
TO FACE.
AND ACKNOWLEDGE.
WHAT SEEMS TO BE IMPOSSIBLE?
IN THE WAY OF CHANGE.
TO LABOR THROUGH CONCERTED
EFFORT AND A CLEAR VISION.
TO MOVE FROM THE IMPOSSIBLE.
TO THE POINT WHERE AS IT BEGINS
TO LOOK.
POSSIBLE BUT STILL AS YET
IMPROBABLE.
AND AND YOU ARE SURE IN THAT DAY
WHEN YOU LOOK BACK AND YOU SAY
WELL IT BECAME INEVITABLE.
WE FACE MANY ISSUES IN OUR
STATE.
ISSUES OF DOMINATED THE
CONVERSATION SINCE LAST FALL OR
FOR DECADES.
W. CONFRONTED IT LOOKS
IMPOSSIBLE.
AND IT'S ARE WORKED OF MAKE IT
IMPROBABLE AND THEN INEVITABLE
BRING CHANGE.
THAT'S A GREAT WORK OF OUR LABOR
IN A DELIBERATE OF DEMOCRACY.
AND THEN JUST BECAUSE
I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF THE FOR
ALSO WANTED KNOWLEDGE THAT.
AS INDIA BECAME A NATION.
A GREAT BENGALI POET
RABINDRANATH TAGORE.
WHO IN NINETEEN THIRTEEN
RECEIVED THE NOBEL PRIZE FOR
LITERATURE?
PENNED THE LYRICS WHICH BECAME
THE INDIAN NATIONAL ANTHEM.
BUT HE HE HAD SOMETHING TO SAY
ABOUT PUBLIC SERVICE.
WHICH IS.
FRANKLY BEAUTIFUL.
HE SAYS A PUBLIC SERVICE AND OF
SERVING OTHERS HE SAYS.
I SLEPT.
AND DREAMT.
THAT LIFE WAS JOY.
I AWOKE.
AND SAW THAT LIFE WAS SERVICE.
I ACTED AND BEHOLD SERVICE
WAS JOY.
SO COLLEAGUES AS WE REMEMBER THE
GREAT.
NATION OF INDIA THE EVOLUTION OF
ITS YEARS.
THE WORK OF ITS PEOPLE ACROSS
DECADES
AND AT THE HEART OF ANY
DEMOCRACY THE SERVICE OF
INDIVIDUALS.
GREAT TO BE HERE IN SUPPORT
THIS.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY.
AND MISTER KANSEN CHU.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FROM YOUR
DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKERS ARE
MEMBERS TIME.
PROUD TO RISE TO BE A PRINCIPAL
CALL AUTHOR OF ACRONE FORTY
SEVEN.
THE OTHER ONE THE THINK MY
COLLEAGUES FROM SAN JOSE. TO
OTHER OAK AUTHORED THIS BILL.
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF ABOUT
EIGHTY THOUSAND INDOOR AMERICANS
IN MY DISTRICT I LIKE TO TAKE
THIS EVENT A DID. THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK THEM FOR
THEIR CONTRIBUTION TO. OUR VERY
VERY A VIBRANT AND DIVERSE OF A
COMMUNITY OF ONE OF THE
ORGANIZATION BASED IN MY COMEY
COMING COMMUNITY. THIS CALL
FEDERATION OF INDOOR AMERICANS
THEY ORGANIZED THE LARGEST OF
PER RATE BY SALT IS THE
MISSISSIPPI. OR DOING A.
UNTIL INDEPENDENCE DAY AND IN
JULY AND ALSO DAY HOW ORGANIZED
THE.
TO FOX OF FAST A BOWL OF GOLD.
TO BRING UP AT ALL COMMITTEE TO
GET HER TO HAVE THE OR
INTERNATIONAL A OF A MOVIE THEIR
THEATERS SO. I WANT TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK OF DOC
DOCTOR JOB PROGRAM I HAD A
CONSTITUENT OFF MY. AND THE US
BUT THE.
OF FOUNDER OF FY A FOR HIS
CONTINUE A EFFORT. TO TO GO TO
BRING OUR COMMUNITY ALTOGETHER
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS YOU.
ALL DISCUSSION HAVING CEASED.
MISTER KALRA YOU MAY CLOSE ON
THE RESOLUTION THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER LIKE TO THANK ALL THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON ACR
ONE FORTY SEVEN.
THIS IS CO AUTHORS.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE THERE SEVENTY ONE CO
AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION
WHOM WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED AND MISTER KALRA BACK
TO YOU FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTION RELATIVE TO THE
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I JUST
WANT TO BRIEFLY RECOGNIZE.
ALTHOUGH WE DO HAVE A VIBRANT
INDEED AMERICAN THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THERE'S NO DOUBT HERE THE
SACRAMENTO REGION WE'D HAVE ONE
OF THE MOST VIBRANT AND LONG
LASTING AB EIGHT COMMUNITIES ARE
VERY PROUD. TO HAVE A NUMBER OF
OUR LEADERS ARE HERE IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA.
HERE TO RECOGNIZE INDIA
REPUBLIC DAY WITH ALL OF US
PLEASE WELCOME THEM
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY NINE.
IS FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING A SEE
OUR.
ONE FIFTY SIX THE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FIFTY SIX BY FINE MEMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AND OTHERS
BILLETED LOW RELATIVE TO CHRONIC
DRAMATIC EXAMPLE OFF THE.
THIS GONZALEZ FLETCHER ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU KNOW.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
HAULED RIGHT.
TYLER CORNELL.
JOSEPH CHERNOV SH.
CODY HAMBLIN.
SCOTT ROSS.
JUNIOR SEAU.
DAVID DURSUN.
KEN STABLER.
MIKE JENKINS.
DR MICHAEL KING.
PAUL PENDER.
THESE ARE JUST A FEW OF THE
NAMES
PEOPLE'S WHOSE LIVES.
HAVE BEEN RASH RAVISHED.
AND FACE UNTIMELY DEATHS BECAUSE
OF C. T. E..
CT IS A HORRIBLE DEGENERATIVE
BRAIN DISEASE THAT CAN OCCUR IN
PEOPLE WITH A HISTORY OF
REPETITIVE HEAD TRAUMA. SUCH AS
THOSE WHO PLAY CONTACT SPORTS
SERVICE MEMBERS AND VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC ABUSE.
SYMPTOMS SUCH AS CONFUSION
IMPAIRED JUDGMENT AGGRESSIVE
BEHAVIORS AND PROGRESSIVE
DEMENTIA CAN DEVELOP YEARS AFTER
THE LAST BRAIN TRAUMA AND HAVE
BEEN DOCUMENTED DOCUMENTED
IMPATIENCE.
AS YOUNG AS EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD.
SO MUCH WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
PREVENT THIS DISEASE FROM
SPREADING AND TAKING OUR
FAMILIES HOSTAGE. ACR ONE FIFTY
SIX
pCT c AWARENESS DAY.
THERE'S A REASON IT COMES RIGHT
BEFORE SUPERBOWL.
IT RECOGNIZES THE WORK OF
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
DEDICATED TO RAISING PUBLIC
AWARENESS OF THIS MIND ROBBING
DISEASE AND PROMOTES BUT
SPROCKETS IS THE PROTECT OUR
YOUNG CHILDREN IN COMMUNITIES.
FROM PREVENTABLE DISEASE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON ACR ONE FIFTY SIX AND
WOULD LIKE TO OPEN THE FIRST
ROLE FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE RESOLUTION.
THE AUTHORS ASKING THAT THE
FIRST ROLE WE OPENED FOR CO
AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
A CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
CO AUTHORS ON ACR ONE FIFTY SIX.
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
THE CLERK.
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE
SIXTY NINE CO AUTHORS ADDED.
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED MISS GONZALEZ
FLETCHER TO YOU FOR YOUR GAS
INTRODUCTION.
YEAH.
IT'S MY GREAT PLEASURE TO
INTRODUCE MY GUEST TODAY.
KIMBER IS THERE IN THE GALLERY.
KIMBERLY ARCHIE LOST OR SOME
PAUL TO SEE T. E. DESPITE NLY
PLAYING YOUTH FOOTBALL FROM AGE
SEVEN TO FIFTEEN.
JOE CORNELL ALSO LOST HER SON
TYLER TO CT AND HAD ONLY PLAYED
YOUTH AND HIGH SCHOOL FOOTBALL.
MARY SAY OW LUSTER BROTHER
JUNIOR SEAU A FORMER SAN DIEGO
CHARGERS LINEBACKER TO CT HAVING
PLAYED FOOTBALL FROM A YOUNG AGE
INTO HIS ADULT LIFE.
THESE THREE STRONG WOMEN ARE
JUST A FEW OF THE MANY FAMILY
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY CT.
TOGETHER AND ALONGSIDE OTHERS
THE CO FOUNDED THE FACES OF CT
ONE OF THE MANY ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT AIM TO RAISE
AWARENESS AND ADVOCATE FOR SAY
PRACTICES. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING MY GAS AND THANKING
THEM IN THEIR ADVOCACY ON
CURBING CT  IN OUR
COMMUNITIES
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK
TO THE TOP OF THE FILE THE. TOP
OF ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
WHICH IS AB EIGHT EIGHT NINE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS THE
CLERK READ WITH AMENDMENTS.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT EIGHTY NINE
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOMETHING
THAT REMARKS DOWN.
MR STONE ON THE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THE BILL THAT WOULD PROHIBIT
SECRET SETTLEMENTS IN CASES
WHERE A DEFECT HAS CAUSED
SERIOUS BODILY HARM OR DEATH AND
WOULD CONTINUE TO DO SO. BUT FOR
SUN SHINING THAT THE FACT
THROUGH THE PROCESS THESE
AMENDMENTS CLARIFY THE ROLE OF
THE JUDGES WHAT THEY NEED TO
LOOK FOR AND ASK FOR THE WORK
THAT THEY NEED TO DO AND
ENSURES.
THAT THEY DO NOT IN FACT NEED TO
INSPECT ALL OF THE DOCUMENTS AND
HOLD HEARINGS ON ALL THE
DOCUMENTS THAT OUR SIDE.
UNLESS THOSE DOCUMENTS.
JOE THAT SPECIFIC THE FACT THE
JUDGES SO CA SO WE'VE BEEN
WORKING VERY HARD TO PART WITH
THEM THEY HAVE COME OFF THIS
BILL IN OPPOSITION WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST. AN AYE
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER STONE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE AMENDMENTS AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED. BILLS OUT OF PRINT
AND BACK ON FILE.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM.
NUMBER SIX.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
AND FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN.
AS AB THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR FOR
THE PURPOSE.
OF AMENDMENTS MISTER GLORIA.
THE CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY
FOUR WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA MISTER
GLORY ON THE AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I
PRESENT AMENDMENTS FOR AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR HE'S
AMENDMENTS ALLOW FOR ADDITIONAL
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO UTILIZE
THIS NEW WAY OF APPLYING
TRANSACTIONAL AND USE TAXES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK MY COLLEAGUES
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA MISS
WALDRON. WE OPPOSE THE
AMENDMENTS AND
FOR ROLL CALL.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
ROLL CALL VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS.
A CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. I'M
GOOD WISH TO VOTE HOMEOWNERS
VOTER WISH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS WHO WISH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE ANTI VOTE AYE AYES
FORTY THREE.
KNOWS TWENTY THREE THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE BILL
IS OUT OF PRINT.
AND BACK ON FILE
.
MEMBERS IN FILE ORDER THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER. EIGHT ACR ONE
FORTY CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT LUCIEN ONE
FORTY FAISALY MEMBER BONTA
RELATIVE TO HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AWARENESS MONTH. MISTER BONTA ON
THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT ACR ONE FORTY A
RESOLUTION DECLARING THE MONTH
OF JANUARY AS HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AWARENESS MONTH.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS A ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY BILLION DOLLAR
GLOBAL INDUSTRY THE FASTEST
GROWING CRIMINAL ENTERPRISE. IN
THE WORLD AND CALIFORNIA HAS THE
HIGHEST NUMBER. OF INCIDENTS
REPORTED IN THE NATION ACCORDING
TO THE NATIONAL HUMAN
TRAFFICKING HOTLINE. THIS MONTH
IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO BRING
AWARENESS TO THE ISSUE OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
TO THAT ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
VICTIMS IN THE UNITED STATES AND
FORTY MILLION VICTIMS GLOBALLY
IN AN EFFORT TO COMBAT. THIS
HUMAN TRAGEDY.
TO PROTECT
OUR YOUTH AND STOP THIS CRIME
BEFORE IT STARTS LAST YEAR
INTRODUCED AB TWELVE TWENTY
SEVEN THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
PREVENTION EDUCATION. AND
TRAINING ACT WHICH THIS
RESOLUTION BUILDS UPON AB TWELVE
TWENTY SEVEN WAS SIGNED INTO LAW
BY GOVERNOR BROWN IN OCTOBER AND
AS OF THIS JANUARY PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. ARE NOW REQUIRED TO
OFFER EDUCATION AND TRAINING ON
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IDENTIFICATION
AND PREVENTION IN ORDER TO
PROTECT CHILDREN FROM BEING
EXPLOITED FOR LABOR. AND SEX
THIS JANUARY THE PROCLAMATION OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AWARENESS
MONTH ALONG WITH THE STATEWIDE
IMPLEMENTATION OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING PREVENTION EDUCATION
AND TRAINING WILL CONTINUE TO
MAKE CALIFORNIA A NATIONAL.
AND A GLOBAL LEADER IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST HUMAN TRAFFICKING
MEMBERS I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING ACR ONE FORTY I
REQUEST WE OPEN THE FIRST ROLE
FOR CO AUTHORS. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU RESPONDED MISSED
BAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I THINK OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
VARIOUS FOR BRINGING THIS
RESOLUTION FORWARD AND WHAT JUST
WANT TO ALSO STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT. FIRST UNDERSCORE JUST
HOW FAST A HAVE FAST GROWING
CRIME HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN IS IT
THE IT IS THE FASTEST GROWING
CRIME IN THE UNITED STATES. AND
HUMAN TRAFFICKING OF MINOR GIRLS
IS THE FASTEST GROWING CRIME IN
PARTICULAR.
IN THE IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
THREE OF THE FBI'S THIRTEEN
WORST SITES FOR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING THEY'RE IN OUR SOME
OF OUR MAJOR CITIES HEARING
CALIFORNIA THE TOP THREE. AND
IT'S NOT JUST SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENS FAR AWAY IN DIFFERENT
LANDS THE FBI HAS FOUND THAT
SEVENTY TWO PERCENT.
OF THOSE ON THEY'RE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS LIST ARE YOU
S. RESIDENTS.
AND IT DOESN'T JUST HAPPEN IN
BIG CITIES BACK ALLEYS AND
OTHERWISE IN MY DISTRICT ALONE
IN MY FIRST THREE YEARS IN
OFFICE.
THREE HUMAN TRAFFICKING RINGS
ARE BROKEN UP INCLUDING ONE OF
THE LARGEST ONES IN THE COUNTRY
IT HAPPENS. EVERYWHERE IT IS
PARTICULARLY IT'S IT'S A
HORRIBLE CRIME BUT IT'S
PARTICULARLY ONE THAT'S
VICTIMIZING CHILDREN. EVERY TWO
MINUTES.
IN THE UNITED STATES IS STYLED A
CHILD IS SOLD IT TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
PARTICULARLY SEX TRAFFICKING.
AND IT IS A CRIME THAT IS
GROWING WE'RE COMING UP TO THE
SUPERBOWL THIS WEEKEND THE
SUPERBOWL WHEN IT CAME TO
CALIFORNIA WAS KNOWN AS A PLACE
WHERE. A GREAT SPORTS HAPPEN BUT
ALSO WERE HUMAN TRAFFICKING WAS
RAMPANT.
THERE'S A LOT THAT WE CAN DO.
FIRST IT STARTS WITH BECOMING
AWARE AND SPREADING THAT
AWARENESS IN OUR DISTRICTS WE
NEED TO BETTER PROSECUTE THESE
CRIMES AND BETTER PREVENT THEM.
AND ONE OF THE AREAS WHERE WE
HAVE. WHEN THE GREATEST GAPS.
IS NOT ONLY IN PROSECUTION TO
THE FULL EXTENT OF THE LAW WHICH
IS HELPED BY VERTICAL
PROSECUTION BUT IT'S AN HELPING
VICTIMS RECOVER.
I RECENTLY MET WITH A GROUP.
IN THE BAY AREA YOU SPARE A
CALLED NEW DAY FOR CALIFORNIANS
AND THIS IS A GROUP THAT HELPS
MINOR CHILDREN WHO'VE BEEN
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
RECOVER.
THERE ARE LESS THAN TWO HUNDRED
BEDS IN THE ENTIRE UNITED
STATES.
FOR HELPING MINOR CHILDREN
RECOVER FROM HUMAN TRAFFICKING
WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I VOTE AND
I THINK OUR COLLEAGUE FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISS BAKER.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON
THE RESOLUTION MR BONTA HAS
ASKED THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE
OPEN.
FOR A CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION CARPOOL UP THE ROLE.
NUMBER SYSTEMS COOPER'S CHO
AUTHORS ADDING ONTO ACR ONE
FORTY.
S. CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE THERE SEVENTY TWO CO
AUTHORS ADDED IN WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED
SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THAT RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
WE ARE IT FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE
THAT IS AB ELEVEN BY MR MCCARTY
THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME OF ELEVEN BY SOMEONE MEMBER
MCCARTY AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
THE MEDICAL.
THIS MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
MEASURE WOULD IMPROVE
DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENINGS FOR
CHILDREN'S THEIR THROUGH THREE
UNDER THE EARLY AND PERIODIC
SCREENING DIAGNOSIS AND
TREATMENTS. BENEFIT UNDER
MEDICARE HOW WE KNOW THAT EIGHTY
FIVE PERCENT OF BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT OCCURS WITH KIDS
ZERO THREE THREE THE FIRST THREE
YEARS OF LIFE WE ALSO IN
CALIFORNIA ABOUT FORTY SEVEN
PERCENT OF OUR KIDS LIVE IN
POVERTY.
COMPROMISES ARE LONG TERM WELL
BEING WELLBEING.
FURTHER MORE CALIFORNIA RANKS
FORTY THIRD THE NATION FOR
DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENINGS
AND THAT THIS WILL ATTEMPT TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE WE KNOW THAT
EARLY IDENTIFICATION WORKS.
CAN IMPROVE THE CHILD'S LONG
TERM. OUTCOME AND INCREASE.
DEVELOP MOST SCREENINGS ALSO
COMES WITH INCREASED SERVICES TO
HELP YOUNG CHILDREN THRIVE IN
CALIFORNIA ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
MISTER BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AS A JOINT AUTHOR I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF. AB ELEVEN
WHICH TO HELP ENSURE THAT SOME
OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REACH THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL BY HAVING A. TIMELY
DEVELOPMENTS WE LOOK WE JUST
HAVE BEEN DOING ENOUGH.
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE.
MY COLLEAGUES SACRAMENTO'S
LEADERSHIP AND PUSHING ON THIS
ISSUE OF MAKING SURE THAT SOME
OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN
HAVE A. HEAD START AND EARLY
START LIFE IN A FAIR START LIFE
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK DRIVE UP.
THANK YOU MISS BONTA.
SHE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CORPORAL. I'M VOTERS OUT OF
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TELL YOU THAT I
SEVENTY ONE KNOWS ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN IS A BE
EIGHTY SEVEN CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY SEVEN BY
FAMILY MEMBER TING AND OTHERS IN
ATLANTA VEHICLES.
MISTER TING EMAIL BUT.
THANK YOU BUT SPEAKER A. B.
EIGHTY SEVEN REQUIRES COMPANIES
TESTING DRIVER LOS.
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES TO PROVIDE
LOCAL AUTHORITIES WITH THE
WRITTEN NOTICE AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WITH A LAW
ENFORCEMENT INTERACTION PLAN.
THE DMV HAS PROPOSED REGULATIONS
THAT WILL ALLOW DRIVERLESS
AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES WITH OUT A
BACKUP HUMAN DRIVER. TO BE
TESTED ON OUR PUBLIC ROADWAYS.
ALL BUT UNFORTUNATELY BEEN
WORKING ON THESE REGULATIONS FOR
OVER TWO AND A HALF YEARS AND WE
STILL DON'T KNOW EXACTLY. WHEN
THEY'LL BE DONE.
PROPOSALS VERY SIMPLE.
WE ASK THAT AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE
COMPANIES BEFORE THEY PUT THE
VEHICLES ON THE ROAD. TELL LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT WHERE THE
VEHICLES ARE GOING.
HOW TO SHUT THAT DOWN BECAUSE IT
WON'T HAVE HUMAN BEINGS IN THEM?
AND ALSO THAT THEY DRAFT A PLAN
WITH LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS GOOD
PUBLIC POLICY.
SOME PRACTICE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR STREETS ARE SAFE.
AT ALL TIMES.
THIS INCIDENT CAME ABOUT A
COUPLE OF LAST YEAR. WHEN A
COMPANY IN SAN FRANCISCO DECIDED
TO PUT IN AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES ON
THE ROAD PRIOR TO RECEIVING
APPROVAL.
WHAT WE FOUND OUT IS THAT OUR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT LOCAL
POLICE DEPARTMENT HAD NO
AUTHORITY?
POLICE CARS OVER AND TO GET THEM
OFF THE ROAD EVEN THOUGH THEY
WERE ON THE ROAD ILLEGAL.
SO THIS PROVISION THAT WE ARE
ASKING FOR ENSURE THAT THERE IS
COMMUNICATION GOING ON BETWEEN
THE COMPANIES A LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. THAT LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT KNOWS AND HAS THE
POWER TO GET THESE VEHICLES OFF
THE ROAD IF THEY'RE DEEMED
UNFIT.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THANK YOU MISTER TANK MISTER
RODRIGUEZ
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY
SEVEN AUTONOMOUS THOMAS VEHICLES
ARE EXCITING AND GETTING BETTER
EVERY DAY. HOWEVER ADVANCEMENT
SHOULD NOT COME AT THE EXPENSE
OF PUBLIC SAFETY.
AB EIGHTY SEVEN IS A COMMONSENSE
MEASURE THAT PROVIDES LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
VITAL INFORMATION WITHOUT
HINDERING THAT BATSMEN OF
TECHNOLOGY.
I OFFER SUPPORT ON AB EIGHTY
SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISS RODRIGUEZ.
SAYING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE A ROLL TIDE VOTE. ICE
FORTY THREE KNOWS TWENTY THREE
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN.
AB THREE TEN.
COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TEN BY SOME
A MEMBER MEDINA AND ATLANTIC
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
MR MEDINA THEY YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT A. B. THREE
TEN.
OVER TWO MILLION CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE MEET UNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS
RELY ON A WORKFORCE OF OVER
FORTY THOUSAND PART TIME FACULTY
MEMBERS.
SPIKE THE TWENTY FIVE PERCENT
GOAL ESTABLISHMENT EDUCATION
CODE IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
FORTY THREE PERCENT OF CREDIT
CLASSES ARE BEING TAUGHT BY PART
TIME FACULTY.
THERE'S A DISTINCT RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN AFTER CLASS ACCESS TO
FACULTY. AND STUDENT SUCCESS.
BUT INFORMATION ON PART TIME
FACULTY OFFICE HOURS ARE NOT
REPORTED.
AB THREE TEN WILL INCLUDE A
REPORTING REQUIREMENT. ON THE
AMOUNT OF PART TIME FACULTY
OFFICE HOURS.
THE DISTRICT LEVEL AND REQUIRE
THAT THIS INFORMATION BE
PUBLICIZED ON THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS WEBSITES.
AB THREE TEN WOULD ALSO SUPPORT
THE GOALS OF THE STUDENT SUCCESS
ACT.
BY INCLUDING THE COLLECTION OF
METRICS
CRITICAL FOR STUDENT SUCCESS.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND IS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MISTER MEDINA.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CORPORAL. HOMEOWNERS FUNDS ARE
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
AND IS THERE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE VOTE
I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE IS AB
FOUR TWENTY SEVEN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR TWENTY SEVEN
BY SOME REMEMBER MERCY CHEN
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
AEROSPACE.
MISTER MERCIER G..
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB FORTY SEVEN CREATES THE
CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE AND
AVIATION COMMISSION.
TO PROVIDE SAY WHY PUBLIC
PRIVATE LEADERSHIP FOR POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE GOVERNOR
AND LEGISLATURE IN SUPPORT OF.
IN OUR STATE PARTICULARLY IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THE LOS ANGELES SOUTH BAY AREA
WHICH I REPRESENT IS HOME TO
MANY OF THE GLOBAL LEADERS OF
INNOVATION. COMPANIES LIKE SPACE
ACTS NORTHRUP. BOEING AND MANY
OTHERS.
THEY PROVIDE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF GOOD PAYING JOBS IN
COULD INCLUDING GOOD PAYING
UNION JOBS.
BUT THERE'S A NATIONAL AND
GLOBAL LEADERSHIP IS CONSTANTLY
BEING THREATENED BY OTHER STATES
THAT WANT TO LEARN OR ARE
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY FROM
CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS.
COMMISSIONS FOR OTHER
INDUSTRIES LIKE THE FILM
COMMISSION AND THE TRAVEL AND
TOURISM COMMISSION HOWEVER
CURRENTLY THERE NO OFFICIAL
STATEWIDE ADVOCATE. WELL FOR THE
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY.
WE MUST CONTINUE TO LEAD THE
NATION. AND THE AEROSPACE
INNOVATION SPACE AND TO CONTINUE
TO GROW GOOD PAYING JOBS IN OUR
STATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CITY.
SAY NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
COR CLUB THE ROLE. ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOTHES A ROLL TIE THAT I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES WE'RE PASSING TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM THIRTEEN.
WE'RE IT FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN.
AB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN THE CLERK
READ ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SIXTY
SEVEN BY SOME A MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA AND ACTUALLY TO ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT.
MISS QUIRK SILVA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
SEVEN SIX SEVEN ESTABLISHES A
SMALL BUSINESS MASTER LICENSE
CENTER WITHIN GO BIDS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF DEVELOPING AND
ADMINISTER. RAIN AND INNER NAY
INTERNET BASED PRODUCTS FORM
THAT ALLOWS BUSINESSES TO IT
ELECTRONICALLY SUBMIT A MASTER
LICENSE AND PERMIT APPLICATION.
THIS BILL LEVERAGES AN EXISTING
GO BIT BIDS WEB BASED PLATFORM
TO BECOME A SINGLE ACCESS POINT
FOR APPLYING TO AND MEETING
EXISTING REQUIREMENTS.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THE US QUIRK SILVA SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE OUT AYE SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN IS AB
EIGHT SIXTY TWO COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AND
ACTUALLY TO CORRECTIONS. MR
MAIENSCHEIN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB EIGHT SIXTY TO
AUTHORIZE THE BOARD OF STATE AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS TO
INCREASE THEIR EXISTING ABILITY
TO ESTABLISH PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS.
AND FACILITATE THE USE OF SOCIAL
INNOVATION FINANCING TO REDUCE
RECIDIVISM.
THIS LEGISLATION WOULD REQUIRE
THE BOARD TO ESTABLISH SIX
COUNTIES TO RECEIVE FUNDING.
AND ISSUE GRANDSON AMOUNT OF NOT
LESS THAN THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND NOT MORE THAN TWO
MILLION DOLLARS AB EIGHT SIXTY
TWO WOULD ALSO EXTEND THE SUNSET
OF THEPROGRAM. TO JANUARY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU AND
I RESPECT YOUR QUESTION I.
THE IT WAS MEASURE I'M SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE RIGHT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN.
AB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY WILL EIGHT SIXTY FIVE
BY SOME A MEMBER LEVINE AND
ACTUALLY THE SENTENCING. MISTER
LEVINE YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN WE PASSED LEGISLATION
TO ALLOW VETERANS WITH SERVICE
INDUCEMENT ALL HEALTH ISSUES ARE
HAVE THEIR SENTENCES REDUCED
WITH AND HAVE IT BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION. THIS BILL AB
EIGHT SIX
THE FIVE LOOKS BACK PRIOR.
THE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AYE TO
ALLOW THEM THE PETITION THE
COURTS TO REDUCE THEIR SENTENCES
LAST FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVINE.
TINO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
I'M VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE.
TELL YOU VOTE AYE SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WHERE FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN
A. B.?
NINE NINE ONE.
CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
NINETY ONE BY SOME A MEMBER
REYES AND ACTUALLY FOSTER YOUTH.
ISRAEL'S YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY I AM PRESENTING AB NINE
NINE ONE A BILL. A BILL WHICH
WOULD ACTIVELY ENHANCE ACCESS
A COMMUNICATION TO A VARIETY OF
CRUCIAL RESOURCES FOR FOSTER
YOUTH.
CURRENTLY INDEPENDENT LIVING
PROGRAMS ARE AYE LP'S ARE COUNTY
RUN PROGRAMS WHICH OFFER
TRAINING SERVICES AND A
MULTITUDE OF OTHER FORMS OF
ASSISTANCE.
CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH.
ALL WITH THE GOAL OF EMPOWERING
THOSE WITHIN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM TO ACHIEVE SELF
SUFFICIENCY.
CURRENTLY HOWEVER THERE IS NO
REQUIREMENT THAT I'M FOR
INFORMATION REGARDING THESE
CRITICAL PROGRAMS BE
CONSISTENTLY POSTED OR UPDATED.
A. B. NINE NINE ONE WOULD
REQUIRE COUNTIES AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
TWO ON THEIR RESPECTIVE WEBSITES
POST AND UPDATE INFORMATION
ANNUALLY ON ILP PLANS AND
CONTACT INFORMATION FOR
ADMINISTERED PROGRAMS SO THAT
FOSTER YOUTH CAN ACCESS THESE
IMPORTANT PROGRAMS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THEY GIVE US RENTS SENIOR
DISCUSSION. OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OUT I SEVENTY
ONE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN AB TEN THIRTY SEVEN
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN THIRTY SEVEN
BY SOME THE NUMBER THE MOUND AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION. MS LAMAR
YOU MAY OPEN.
I THINK YOU AND MISTER SPEAKER
CALIFORNIA HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
EMBRACING ALL OF OUR STUDENTS
INCLUDING DREAMERS.
TODAY'S ADD FOR AT BILL IN ACTS
MEASURES TO ALLOW THEM TO ACCESS
CERTAIN BENEFITS THAT MAKE
HIGHER EDUCATION MORE AFFORDABLE
AND ATTAINABLE. EXISTING LAW
PROVIDES IN STATE TUITION KNOWN
AS AB FIVE FORTY AND THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT PROVIDES
EIGHTY FIVE FORTY STUDENTS
ACCESS TO CAL GRANT PROGRAMS
INSTITUTIONAL FINANCIAL AID. AND
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES BOARD OF
GOVERNORS FEE WAIVER. AB TEN
THIRTY SEVEN ESTABLISHES THE CAL
GRANT BE SERVICE INCENTIVE GRANT
PROGRAM UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
SOON EIGHT COMMISSION AND MAKES
THIS PROGRAM AVAILABLE TO
CALIFORNIA DREAMERS.
THIS BILL PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR ELIGIBLE AB FIVE
FORTY STUDENTS TO PROVIDE A
SERVICE IN THEIR COMMUNITY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ACCESS INCENTIVE
GRANTS TO HELP FILL THEIR AND
MEANT FINANCIAL AID. GAPS
AB TEN THIRTY SEVEN FURTHERS
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TO SUPPORT
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS VIA
STATEWIDE AVAILABILITY OF A
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE STUDENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO EXPLORE AND GAIN
EXPERIENCE IN THEIR SELECTIVE
CAREER PATH
I ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO HAS
GIVEN SEVERAL UNLESS A PIN
TODAY.
IN SUPPORT OF OUR DREAMER
STUDENTS
SO WITH THAT I ASK I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON AB TEN THIRTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISS AMONG MISS
CARILLO. YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU WITH SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TEN THIRTY SEVEN.
AS THEY FORMALLY UNDOCUMENTED
YOUTH MYSELF I UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS MEASURE WHICH
WOULD PROVIDE AN IMPORTANT
OPPORTUNITY FOR UNDOCUMENTED AB
FIVE FORTY STUDENTS TO EARN A
WORK STUDY FINANCIAL AID THAT
THEY'RE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR. AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL BY ALLOWING
DREAMERS ACCESS TO THE CAL GRANT
BE SERVICE INCENTIVE GRANT
PROGRAM WE ARE FILLING. OUR
COMMUNITIES TO THE EAST OUR
COMMITMENTS TO THE STUDENTS AND
SUPPORTING THEM IN THEIR EFFORTS
TO ACHIEVE THE AMERICAN DREAM OF
GRADUATING FROM COLLEGE.
IN A MOMENT WHERE ARE
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS FEEL
THREATENED AND UNDER ATTACK BY
OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THIS LEGISLATIVE
BODY REAFFIRMS OUR BELIEF. THAT
EVERYONE WHO WANTS TO ATTEND AND
GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE GETS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO REGARDLESS
OF THEIR LEGAL OR ECONOMIC
STATUS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS CREEL.
SAYING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CORD LIBERAL. MEMBERS VOTE. THAT
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FOUR NINE.
KNOWS EIGHTEEN. THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
WE'RE FILE ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN.
AB TEN NINETY SEVEN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN NINETY SEVEN
BY SOMETHING MEMBER LEVINE AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE STATE
BEACHES AND PARKS.
MR LEVINE EMAIL. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS WE SEEN
BILLS LIKE THIS BEFORE IT'S TO
BAN SMOKING ON OUR STATE PARKS
AND BEACHES TO PROTECT. THE
HEALTH AND THE ENVIRONMENT OF
CALIFORNIA WHERE WE'VE LED SO
STRONGLY AND THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO GIVE
GOVERNOR BROWN.
I A LEGACY WHERE I HE GETS TO
SIGN THIS BILL RATHER THAN A
FUTURE GOVERNOR I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS LIVING.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. MEMBERS FUNDS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSER ROLLED HOW
THE VOTE. ICE FORTY THREE KNOWS
NINETEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO.
JUMP AHEAD IN THE FILE TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX
IT'S FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
SIX.
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT BY
MISTER JONES SAWYER CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT BY SOME A MEMBER JONES
SAWYER AND ACTUALLY TO CHARTER
SCHOOLS MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT.
SEEKS TO ENSURE BOTH
TRANSPARENCY WITHIN CHARTER
SCHOOL GOVERNANCE.
AND PROPER OVERSIGHT TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC INTEREST.
WHILE THE GENESIS OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS WHAT THE INNOVATE AND
MEET THE SPECIFIC NEEDS OF
STUDENTS
THEY MUST STILL OPERATE IN A
MANNER THAT REINFORCES PUBLIC
TRUST.
AND PROTECTS OUR KIDS RIGHT TO
SUCCEED AND LEARN.
ALL SCHOOLS THAT RECEIVE PUBLIC
FUNDING SHOULD BE HELD TO THE
SAME STANDARD OF ACCOUNTABILITY.
FOR THE BEST INTERESTS OUR
CHILDREN'S EDUCATION AND
ADVANCEMENT.
I'VE HELD SEVERAL MEETINGS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER
ASSOCIATION SCHOOL ASSOCIATION.
AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
DISCUSS FIXING.
THE CONFLICT OF INTEREST PORTION
OF THE BILL. AND LOOKING AT THE
MULTIPLE LOCATIONS THAT YOU CAN
HAVE WERE.
CHARTER SCHOOLS CAN MEET AND
HAVE OPEN MEETINGS.
I'VE ALSO MET WITH THE CHAIR OF
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE WILL
BE WORKING TOGETHER TO CONTINUE
THIS CONVERSATION WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON BOTH SIDES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER
THIS CREEL DIRECTNESS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
TO THE AUTHOR.
BUT CHARTER SCHOOL PARENTS AND
ADVOCATES HAVE RAISED CONCERNS
REGARDING GOVERNMENT CODE TEN
NINETY.
MY DISTRICT IS HOME TO AN
INDIGENOUS.
GROUP OF SCHOOLS.
WHICH TEACHES NOW WHAT MANDARIN
SPANISH AND ENGLISH AND HAS
REALLY PAVE THE WAY FOR ETHNIC
STUDIES.
WELL I ONE HUNDRED PERCENT
SUPPORT INCREASE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY FOR CHARTER
SCHOOLS I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE DEVELOP A SOLUTION. THAT
ACKNOWLEDGES THE NEED FOR
FLEXIBILITY AROUND CHARTER
SCHOOL GOVERNANCE I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE AUTHOR HAS COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK AND ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS AROUND TEN NINETY CAN
THE AUTHOR CONFIRM THIS
COMMITMENT.
MISTER JONES ARE YOU MAY ADDRESS
AT IN YOUR CLOTHES.
IF YOU WISH MISTER O'DONNELL.
YOU RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. CHARTER SCHOOLS
OPERATE WITH PUBLIC TAX DOLLARS
AND SHOULD FOLLOW THE SAME
CONFLICT OF INTEREST RULES AND
POLICIES THAT APPLY TO SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND OTHER ELECTED
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS.
WE MUST STOP THE WASTE FRAUD AND
FINANCIAL BE USE THAT ARE
CURRENTLY HAPPENING IN SOME.
OF OUR CHARTER SCHOOLS
FOR EXAMPLE.
AN AUDIT OF THE TRI VALLEY
LEARNING CORPORATION IN THE EAST
BAY.
FOUND OF THE CHARTER IN
INTERMINGLED PUBLIC DOLLARS WITH
A PRIVATE BUSINESS.
IT ALSO USE PUBLIC DOLLARS TO
PURCHASE FACILITIES THAT ARE NOW
IN PRIVATE HANDS NOW THAT IN THE
SCHOOLS HAVE NOW CLOSED YET THEY
STILL REMAIN IN PRIVATE HANDS.
THIS IS THE ONLY BILL BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE. THAT PROHIBITS
CHARTER SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS
FROM HAVING A FINANCIAL INTEREST
IN THE DECISIONS MADE BY THE
PORT UPON WHICH THEY SEE SET.
WITHOUT THIS BILL SOME CHARTER
SCHOOLS WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
BOARD MEMBERS FINANCIALLY
INTERESTED IN THE DECISIONS
MADE.
BY THE BOARD.
IT IS UNACCEPTABLE FOR PUBLIC
TAX DOLLARS TO BE SPENT BY
BOARDS WITH ANY FINANCIAL
INTEREST AND I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S COMMITMENT TO WORK ON
THE TEN NINETY PORTION OF THE
BILLS WELL.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL.
ALL DEBATE AND DISCUSSION HAVING
CEASED.
MISTER JONES SAWYER YOU MAY
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AND THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUES.
I AM NOT ONLY COMMITTED.
TO ENSURING.
THAT WE LOOK AT ALL ASPECTS OF
CHARTER GOVERNMENT'S.
AND MOST IMPORTANT.
ENSURING THAT WE CRAFT SOMETHING
THAT SO NARROWLY CRAFTED.
THAT THE GOVERNOR WILL SIGN THE
BILL.
EVERYTHING IS ON THE TABLE AS
FAR AS I'M CONCERNED INTO
NINETY.
WHETHER IT FIX.
WHETHER IT'S TAKING IT OUT.
BUT WHETHER WE COME UP WITH AN
ALTERNATE SOLUTION.
TO REMEDY THIS PROBLEM OF
CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
I AM COMMITTED TO IT.
I'M COMMITTED TO IT ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF GOD A COMMITMENT FROM
THE CHAIR OF EDUCATION.
AND WILL FIGHT HARD TO ENSURE
THAT WE GET SOMETHING THAT.
PEOPLE IN THIS HOUSE.
FEEL COMFORTABLE WHEN IT COMES
BACK HOPEFULLY FOR GETS OUT HERE
IT COMES BACK TO THIS HOUSE.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT EVERYONE.
WILL BE ABLE TO
SIGN ONTO
I MAKING THAT COMMITMENT TO YOU
NOW. AND IF WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
COME UP WITH SOMETHING EQUITABLE
ASSEMBLY THAT A PIECE OF THIS
HOUSE MY MOST IMPORTANT A
GOVERNOR.
I PROMISE YOU'LL WILL NOT MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE BILL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
MR OKAY THANK YOU MISTER ALLEN
WE WERE INTO THE CLOTHES AND
WE'RE INTO THE VOTE.
CLICK LIBERAL. MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOUGH
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE
FOR YOUR PLEASURE.
CALL.
MISTER JONES SAWYER MOVES A
MEMBERS BACK CAN THE PRIOR FILE
ORDER WE ARE AT FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
THAT IS AB TWELVE THIRTY ONE BY
DOCTOR WEBER CARPOOL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE THIRTY ONE
BY SOME THE MEMBER WEBER AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION. DOCTOR
WEBER. YES MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT YOU
AB TWELVE THIRTY ONE. THE MERIT
SALARY ADJUSTMENTS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
EVIDENCE SUGGESTS THAT.
ABOUT TO SEE IF SHE WAS THE ONLY
CALIFORNIA STATE AGENCY THAT
DOES NOT PROVIDE SALARY STEPS TO
ITS STAFF.
THIS CREATES AN INVERSION AND
SALAS WHERE NEW HIRES ARE
EARNING MORE THAN MORE
EXPERIENCED EMPLOYEES.
IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX THE CSU
BOARD OF TRUSTEES UNILATERALLY
ELIMINATED EXISTING EMPLOYEES
DAHLE STEPS.
INCREASING INCREASES TIED TO JOB
PERFORMANCE AND LONGEVITY.
THIS IS RESULTED IN NEW HIRES
EARNING HIGHER SALARIES IN
EXISTING EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE
WORKED IN THE SAME
CLASSIFICATION FOR MANY YEARS.
THIS IN EQUITY HAS CREATED A
NINETY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
VERSION GAP BETWEEN THE SAUDIS
OF NEWLY HIRED AND LONG EMPLOYED
SEE ISSUE STAFF.
FOR TWO DECADES SEE ISSUE HAS
BEEN WILL UNWILLING TO REINSTATE
THE DAHLE STEPS DESPITE THE
FAILURE OF THE EXISTING DAHLE
STRUCTURE. AND THE INABILITY OF
EMPLOYEES TO EARN A FAIR AND
EQUITABLE WAIT.
AB TWELVE THIRTY ONE WILL
REINSTATE THE FIVE PERCENT DAHLE
STEP WAS CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SUPPORT STAFF NOW
EMPHASIZE THAT THIS IS SUPPORT
STAFF. BECAUSE THIS IS NOT
FACULTY AND THOSE WHO BREAK THE
GREATER SALAS WITH THOSE WHO ARE
THE JANITORS THE CUSTODIANS OF
THOSE WHO WORK AROUND THE
UNIVERSITY.
THIS INCREASE WILL BE MADE
ANNUALLY WHEN EMPLOYEES MEET THE
STANDARDS OF THIS IS A MERIT
INCREASE AND NOT JUST AN
AUTOMATIC INCREASE THAT EXIST.
MEMBERS MAINTAINING A HIGH
QUALITY C. ISSUE DEPENDS ON THE
RETENTION OF EXPERIENCED
EMPLOYEES INVESTED IN THE LONG
TERM HEALTH AND GROWTH OF
UNIVERSITY.
THE CURRENT DAHLE STRUCTURE DOES
NOT FACILITATE THIS
AB TWELVE THIRTY ONE WOULD
RETURN A POLICY WAS THE ISSUE
STAFF TO PAY LIKE OTHER STATE
EMPLOYEES AND SEE ISSUE
MANAGEMENT.
THE FIVE PERCENT INCREASE IS ON
PAR WITH WHAT'S THE ISSUE STAFF
USED TO GET BEFORE NINETEEN
NINETY SIX AND IS IN LINE WITH
WHAT OTHER STATE EMPLOYEES
RECEIVE.
AGAIN THESE PAY RAISES WOULD BE
MERIT BASED AND NOT OUT OF MATIC
AND THEY REQUIRE AN ASSESSMENT
OF PERFORMANCE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK ME I BOTH AB TWELVE THIRTY
ONE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER MISTER
ALLEN YOU'RE RIGHT SHE OTHER.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
CAN YOU NAME ONE PRIVATE COMPANY
IN CALIFORNIA GIVES AUTOMATIC
REYES OF FIVE PERCENT OF
EMPLOYEES EVERY SINGLE YEAR JUST
FOR SHOWING UP. I NEVER WORK IF
A PRIVATE COMPANY BEFORE I'VE
ALWAYS WORKED NONPROFITS A STATE
INSTITUTION LIKE YOU VERY MUCH.
ON MY OWN TIME ALL THIS IS THE
PROBLEM WITH THE DAYS CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE WE HAVE A BILL BEING
PROPOSED BY AN AUTHOR WHO HAS
NEVER WORKED IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR.
THE AUTHOR NOW WANTS TO GIVE
THESE EMPLOYEES AN AUTOMATIC
FIVE PERCENT RAISE EVERY SINGLE
YEAR THAT THEY JUST SHOW UP FOR
WORK.
THIS IS THE PROBLEM IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY THIS IS WHY OUR
STATE BUDGET IS OUT OF CONTROL.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THERE IS NO
PRIVATE COMPANY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHERE YOU CAN GET AN
AUTOMATIC FIVE PERCENT RAISE
EVERY YEAR. IF THIS BILL PASSES
I WOULD URGE EVERY SINGLE
CALIFORNIA TO APPLY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM SO THEY CAN GET ONE OF
THE ABSOLUTE BEST JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THESE JOBS
SIMPLY DON'T EXIST IN THE REAL
WORLD. THIS BILL HAS NO REAL
THINKING IN IT AND IT IS
AUTHORED BY SOMEONE WHO HAS
NEVER WORKED IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR.
I URGE NO VOTE.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT. OF THIS BILL.
PERHAPS I'M WE COULD ALL READ
THE BILL WHERE IT STATES THAT
IT'S A MERIT BASED STEP.
THAT MEANS YOU'RE EVALUATED
BASED ON PERFORMANCE.
I I I THINK THAT'S A GREAT IDEA
AND ALTHOUGH I'M SURE.
THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE WHO WOULD
LIKE A JOB.
WITH OUR CAL STATE SYSTEM IF YOU
DO WANT TO BE A FOOD HANDLER A
CUSTODIAN.
WE DO THINK THAT YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE TO NOT LIVE IN POVERTY
RIGHT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
SEE NO EDITION ALL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
ON THE ITEM DOCTOR WEBER YOU MAY
CLOSE YES MISTER SPEAKER I GUESS
I SHOULD CORRECTED I WAS TALKING
ABOUT MY PROFESSIONAL LIFE IN
TERMS OF THINGS I'VE DONE AS A
PROFESSOR. I DID WORK FOR A DAY
DAY NEWBERRY'S ONCE WHEN I WAS
IN COLLEGE I HAVE WORKED FOR
PRIVATE ENTITIES.
ENTITY BEFORE. AS POINTED OUT
THIS IS THIS IS WHERE IT'S OUR
INCREASE IN THIS IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WHEN YOU WORK AT A
COMPANY AND YOU ARE STUCK IN A
POSITION.
AND YOU DON'T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE UP BASED ON
YOUR PERFORMANCE IN THIS IS
MERIT BASIS IS NOT JUST
AUTOMATIC THIS IS MERIT BASE. IT
BECOMES REALLY DEMORALIZING FOR
THOSE WHO WORK HERE.
WHEN I FIRST WENT TO THE
UNIVERSITY I'VE AYE AYE THEY HAD
MERIT STEP INCREASES AMONG
FACULTY. AND AS A RESULT AND
ANALYSTS ALSO AMONG STAFF AND AS
A RESULT OF THE VALUATION OF
YOUR ADMINISTRATOR IN TERMS OF
THE THINGS YOU DONE THERE WERE
FIVE STEPS AT EVERY POSITION.
AND YOU HAD A CHANCE TO EARN
YOUR WAY TO WORK UP THAT LADDER
TO A HIGHER PAY. AND THEREFORE
WAS AN INCENTIVE FOR DOING THAT
WHEN THEY TOOK THIS AWAY I WAS
CHAIR OF THE DEPARTMENT. AND
HERE I WAS EVERY YEAR EVALUATING
MY STAFF EVALUATING MY
ADMINISTRATIVE COORDINATOR WOULD
KNOW THE NO OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE
THE PERSON UP OR ANYWHERE ELSE
WOULD JUST DOING THE VALUATION
SETTING GOALS AND OBJECTIVES
INVOICE AND EVALUATING WHERE
THEY WERE MEETING THEM. AND
THERE WAS NO INCENTIVE FOR THEM
TO DO IT NOW THEY DID OFTENTIMES
BECAUSE THEY PRIDED HIMSELF IN
THE WORK THAT THEY DID.
BUT THERE WAS NO INCENTIVE THAT
WAS BUILT IN THIS IS WHAT GOOD
COMPANIES DO IF YOU LOOK AT A
COMPANY IS WHAT THE GOVERNMENT
DOES IS WHAT ALL OF OUR AGENCIES
DO. TO INCENTIVIZE OUR FOLKS TO
WORK HARD TO KNOW THAT THERE IS
MERIT ATTACHED TO IT THAT THEIR
RAISES THAT COME BUT RAISES
DON'T COME BECAUSE OF MAYOR THEY
COME BECAUSE OF THE ECONOMIC
TIMES BEING BETTER. AND MAYBE
THE MARKET PLACES CHANGE OF THE
JOB DESCRIPTION THE DEFINITIONS
OF CHAINS AND THEREFORE THEY
GIVE A THREE PERCENT EVERYBODY
ACROSS THE BOARD BUT MERITED IT
INCREASES THE STEPS ARE FOR
MERIT. AND THAT'S IMPORTANT AND
WE SHOULD NOT THE FACT THAT THIS
IS THE ONE AGENCY THE STAFF
MEMBERS THE CLASSIFIED MEMBERS
OF THE C. ISSUE THAT DO NOT HAVE
MERIT INCREASES AND WE SHOULD
HAVE THE. THE THE DESIRE TO
CREATE THE FAIRNESS AS WELL AS
TO GIVE THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK HARD AND US TO SAY THANK
YOU BY HAVING AN INCREASE A STEP
INCREASE WHEN THEY A BASICALLY
ACCOMPLISH THEIR GOALS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK ON BEHALF OF
THE FACULTY IN ALL ALSO BEHALF
OF THE STAFF OF THE SEA ISSUE
THAT WE INSTITUTE A STEP
INCREASE BYPASSING AB TWELVE
THIRTY ONE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THEY DUCKED WEBER AND WITHOUT
CLERK WILL OPEN.
MEMBERS VOTE.
IS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE AND
TALENTED OF.
I FORTY NINE KNOWS FIFTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WEIRD FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
ONE AB TWELVE SIXTY TWO.
COOPERATE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
SIXTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA AND ACTUALLY TO
CRIMES.
MISTER GARCIA. MISTER SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES AB TWELVE SIXTY
TWO IS A.
SIMPLE. BILL THAT I HOPE YOU'VE
ALL READ.
IT HAS TO DO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
GANG CRIME AND VIOLENCE
PREVENTION PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM.
THAT WILL NOW INCLUDE BORDER
TOWNS.
OF CALIFORNIA TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THESE RESOURCES.
FOR THE PURPOSE OF INVESTING IN
OUR NONPROFIT SECTORS ARE
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS.
FOR GANG VIOLENCE AND PREVENTION
OF OUR YOUTH.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GARCIA.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLERK LIBERAL. ON THE RISK. THAT
A VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE THAT I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY TO PASS
AND RETAIN.
WE'RE FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
THREE.
AB FIFTEEN ELEVEN. CORKERY.
SOME LEGAL FIFTEEN ELEVEN BY
SOME A MEMBER LOW ACTUALLY TO
SENTENCING. MR LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
ELEVEN REINSTATES EXCESSIVE
TAKINGS.
A WHICH IS THE STATUTE AND THIS
IS ADJUSTED FOR THE COST OF
INFLATION. THIS CODE SECTION IS
USING THE PROSECUTION AND
SENTENCING OF CRIMINALS WHO
INFLICT THE LOSS OF SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR MORE. ON
THEIR VICTIMS WITHOUT THIS BILL
A CRIMINAL IMPOSING A LOSS OF
FIVE MILLION. DOLLARS WOULD
SERVE THE SAME TIME AS A
CRIMINAL AND POSING A LOSS OF.
NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS
THIS BILL HAS PASSED UNANIMOUSLY
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
LEYVA SO LOW.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CLERK WILL OVER THERE ALL.
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSER ALTERNATIVE
VOTE I SIX NINE THOSE ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
FOUR AB FIFTEEN FORTY SEVEN
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN FORTY
SEVEN BY SOMETHING NUMBER QUIRK
SILVA AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT MAKING
APPROPRIATION THERE FOR.
MISS QUIRK SILVA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
FIFTEEN FORTY SEVEN MODIFIES THE
DEFINITION OF SMALL BUSINESS
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA AMERICANS
WITH DISABILITY. ACT
SMALL BUSINESS CAPITAL ACCESS
LOAN PROGRAM
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF ELIGIBLE
APPLICANTS
AND TWENTY FIFTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED AND
PROVIDED TEN MILLION. DOLLARS TO
ASSIST SMALL BUSINESSES AND
ACCESSING CAPITAL TO MAKE
NECESSARY CHANGES TO MEET ADA
REQUIREMENTS UNFORTUNATELY TO
DATE NO LOANS HAVE RESULTED FROM
THE PROGRAM AS THE CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON JOBS. AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND THE
ECONOMY I AM COMMITTED TO
GETTING THESE FUNDS DEPLOYED AND
SMALL BUSINESSES FACILITIES
UPDATED TO ALLOW EQUAL ACCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU IS QUIRK SILVA SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE WHO'S OUT OF VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE VOTE I SEVENTY
TWO NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE AND TWENTY FIVE.
HE IS AB SEVENTEEN FIFTEEN
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN FIFTEEN
BY SOME A MEMBER QUIRK SILVA AND
OTHERS THAT KIND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT MAKING APPROPRIATION
THERE FOR.
MISS QUIRK SILVA IF YOU'D LIKE
TO TAKE THAT AMONG.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YES THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. I AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTEEN ESTABLISHES A PROCESS
INCLUDING TIMELINES FOR
SUBMITTING PROPOSALS TO GO BIZ
ON THE STAFF WHICH MEANT OF A
PARTNERSHIP AGREEMENT. TO
OPERATE IN INTERNATIONAL TRADE
AND FOREIGN INVESTMENT OFFICE
CURRENT LAW PROVIDES GOBIZ WITH
AUTHORITY TO ESTABLISH FOREIGN
OFFICES AND SPECIFIES WHICH
ACTIONS GOBIZ IS TO TAKE ONCE A
DETERMINATION IS. TO MOVE
FORWARD HAS BEEN MADE SO
ESSENTIALLY A WE HAVE INTEREST
IN ESTABLISHING THESE FOREIGN
TRADE OFFICES WE JUST NEED TO
SET THE. UC PARAMETERS OF HOW
THEY ARE TO APPLY A WITH THIS
BILL UP BECAUSE OF THE STATE LAW
IS SILENT ON HOW TO ACT OUTSIDE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT ENTITIES
CAN RECOMMEND. A PROPOSED THIS
IS STILL AT ESTABLISHMENT OF
ADMINISTERING FOREIGN TRADE
OFFICES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS QUIRK SILVA SEE
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE. SARAH VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS OUT OF
THEM.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE ANTI VOTE I SEVENTY
ONE.
NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN.
WE'VE ALREADY DISPENSED WITH
FILE ITEMS TWENTY EIGHT AND
TWENTY NINE PASS AND RETAIN A
FILE ITEM THIRTY.
THAT BRINGS US FILE ITEM THIRTY
ONE AB FIVE FIFTY THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FIFTY BY SOME
A MEMBER RAY IS ACTUALLY THE
SENIORS.
ISRAEL*.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS.
TODAY I PRISON I AM PRESENTING
AB FIVE FIFTY A BILL WHICH WOULD
MODIFY THE BASE ALLOCATION FOR
LOCAL OMBUDSMAN PROGRAMS IN
YEARS IN WHICH FUNDS ARE MADE
AVAILABLE.
THE LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM IS A FEDERALLY
AUTHORIZED PROGRAM AND SERVES AS
A FIRST LINE OF DEFENSE. FOR
RESIDENTS OF LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES.
OMBUDSMAN ORGANIZATIONS MONITOR
AND ASSIST RESIDENTS IN BOTH
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES SUCH
AS NURSING HOMES AND RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY.
AND ASSISTED LIVING FACILITIES.
CURRENT
FUNDING ALLOCATION FOR THE ALL
TO SEE OMBUDSMAN ORGANIZATIONS
WAS ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE.
AND THEY USED THE EXISTING
FORMULA HAS NOT BEEN UPDATED FOR
INFLATION IN TWENTY SEVEN YEARS.
IT DOES NOT REFLECT THE GROWING
COST OF CONDUCTING BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA.
IN ORDER TO SERVE THE CURRENT
NEEDS OUR AGING POPULATION AND
TO INCREASE SERVICES FOR THE
GROWING POPULATION.
SENIORS IN LONG TERM CARE IT IS
CRITICAL THAT A REALISTIC
ALLOCATION FORMULA IS USED
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS RENTS SEE KNOW
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLERK WILL
OVER THE ROLE. I'M.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUR TO VOTE.
A CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TIE THAT I SEVENTY
FOUR KNOWS ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY TWO. AB FIVE NINETY FIVE
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE NINETY FIVE
BY SOME A MEMBER WOULD ACTUALLY
TO HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLANS.
DOCTOR WOULD. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB FIVE
NINETY FIVE REQUIRES PRIVATE
PRIOR APPROVAL BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE FOR HEALTH
PLAN MERGERS.
AB FIVE REQUIRES DMA SEE TWO ONE
HOLD A PUBLIC HEARING.
TO CONSIDER THE FOLLOWING
FACTORS QUALITY. HEALTH
DISPARITIES AND COMPETITION IN
PLANT PRODUCTS.
THREE PREPARE AN INDEPENDENT
HEALTH CARE IMPACT STATEMENT.
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH INSURANCE
MARKET IS ALREADY VERY
CONCENTRATED THREE CONT
COMPANIES CONTROL NEARLY EIGHTY
PERCENT OF THE MARKET AND OUR
TOP FIVE INSURERS CONTROL NINETY
PERCENT OF THE MARKET.
A SOLID ATION IN THE HEALTH
INSURANCE INDUSTRY CAN OFTEN
MEAN FEWER CHOICES AND
COMPETITION WITH LITTLE TO NO
BENEFIT FOR CONSUMERS ARE
PURCHASERS.
THIS IS WHY THINK THE BILL IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT IN A RURAL
DISTRICT LIKE MINE WHICH THERE
MAY BE ONLY A FEW OPTIONS.
POTENTIALLY LESS ACCESS TO
HEALTH SERVICES.
ADDITIONALLY PRIVATE INSURANCE
PREMIUMS CONTINUE TO RISE AND
OUT OF POCKET SPENDING IS HIGH
AND PROJECTED TO GROW. GIVEN
THESE FACTORS
THE DMA SEAMLESS CRITICALLY
EVALUATE SIGNIFICANT CHANGES IN
THE HEALTH PLAN MARKET AND THEIR
IMPACT ON CONSUMERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AIBO.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD SEE NO
DISCUSSION.
A DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ON MEMBERS BONUS
OUT OF THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE VOTE.
EYES FORTY FIVE KNOWS TWENTY.
THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WERE MOVING BACK IN THE
FILE TO ITEM THIRTEEN AB SIX OH
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX OH FIVE BY
SOME A MEMBER MULLIN AND
ACTUALLY CARE FACILITIES.
MR MOWING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER.
AND MEMBERS AB SIX OH FIVE.
AUTHORIZES THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
TO DEVELOP A SINGLE LICENSE FOR
CHILDCARE CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA.
SERVING CHILDREN FROM BIRTH TO
ENTERING FIRST GRADE.
CURRENT JUL LICENSE SYSTEM IS
ADMINISTRATIVELY BURDENSOME TO
CHILDCARE FACILITY OPERATORS.
IN IS STRUCTURED IN A WAY SO
THAT WE SERVE FAR FEWER INFANTS
THAN PRE SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN
ACROSS THE STATE.
THE CHILD CARE SHORTAGE AFFECTS
FAMILIES THAT MIGHT OTHERWISE
PARTICIPATE IN THE WORK FORCE
AND INDIVIDUALS WHO MIGHT OPEN
CHILD CARE BUSINESSES FILLING
DEMAND FOR CARE.
AND PROVIDING JOBS
MANY ORGANIZATIONS HAVE COME TO
MY OFFICE AND ASK FOR A SOLUTION
TO THIS PROBLEM WHICH IS NOT A
FACT IN HOME CARE PROVIDERS
ONLY.
FACILITY LICENSE CARE.
CALIFORNIA ORIGINALLY CREATED
THIS TOOL LICENSE STRUCTURE IN
AN ATTEMPT TO PROTECT CHILDREN.
AND FOR THAT REASON AB SIX OH
FIVE REQUIRES THAT WE MAINTAIN
THE HIGHEST SAFETY STANDARDS
WHILE SIMPLIFYING THE SYSTEM.
ALLOWING FOR FLEXIBILITY IN THE
BEST INTERESTS OF THE CHILDREN
AS A DRIVING FACTOR IN OUR
ECONOMY THE CHILD CARE SHORTAGE
MUST BE ADDRESSED. AND THIS IS
ONE OF THE MANY CHANGES ALLOWED.
TWO UP ALLOW THE SYSTEM TO SERVE
MORE FAMILIES AND ACHIEVE
EFFICIENCIES WHILE MAINTAINING.
CONTINUITY OF CARE AND WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
I HOPE THAT. THIS IS WITH
RESPECT TO.
CHILD DAYCARE FACILITIES.
AND THE QUESTION IS WITH RESPECT
TO IF THIS IS A VERY PERSONAL
ISSUE TENURE FATHER.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE THIS AYE
IN RECENT DAYS HAS BECOME VERY
PERSONAL.
.
AND HAVE.
SO IS IT IS THAT A PLUS FOR ME
OR THE KIDS ARE MY MY WIFE.
WE BETTER NOT FORGET HER.
THANK YOU JESSICA.
LOOKS AT OUR. THE NUMBER FROM
SOUTH TEMAS IS GO LOOKS
UNUSUALLY RESTED FOR. A THE.
RECENT ACTIVITIES BUT WITH
RESPECT ASPIRIN I.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THEY CAN THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND I FIRST WANT TO SAY I READ
EVERY WORD IT'S A GREAT BILL.
BUT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT HAS
BEEN ON MY MIND IN TERMS OF MY
DAUGHTER AND WHAT HER FUTURE IS
GOING TO LOOK LIKE A PLAN.
THAT WE HAVE FOR A KIDS MOVIE
FLORIDA SO IMPORTANT IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
TAKES A SERIOUS LOOK AT HOW
WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE OUR KIDS
ARE GOING TO BE SUCCESSFUL. IN
THIS NEW WORLD ECONOMY WITH A
NOT WHAT DO NOT JUST COMPETING
AGAINST OUR NEIGHBORS ANYMORE
THE COMPETING AGAINST KIDS FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES IT'S A BIG DEAL
OUT. AND THEN WE WANNA MAKE SURE
WE'RE SETTING OUR KIDS UP FOR
SUCCESS AND I KNOW THAT THIS IS
IMPORTANT TO EVERY SINGLE MEMBER
ON THIS FLOOR REGARDLESS OF
PARTY REGARDLESS OF. ANY OTHER
POLITICAL IDEOLOGY THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ALL.
ONE HUNDRED UNITED WE GONNA
PERCENT UNILATERALLY AGREE ON
AND I JUST WANT.
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL IN
FOR YOU TAKING THE LEAD ON THIS.
MY GOOD COLLEAGUE AND TOO AGAIN
GREW CONGRATULATE YOU ON YOUR
TWO BUNDLES OF JOY IT IS THAT
ONE OF THE BEST THINGS I KNOW
THAT'S EVER HAPPEN TO ME AND I'M
SURE IT'S THE SAME FOR YOU.
AND IT YEAH I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE.
FROM CAMPBELL YOU FOR HAVING
TWINS.
LOOK RIDICULOUSLY WELL WELL
RESTED CONGRADULATIONS YOU YOU
MUST HAVE A WIFE WORKING
OVERTIME MY FRIEND.
MISTER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AS A PROUD MEMBER OF THE TWINS
CAUCUS.
NOW.
MR LE THE GENTLEMAN FROM WOULD
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION AS FAR AS YOU LOOKING
WELL RESTED. I SAY GIVE IT TIME.
MY FRIEND.
AB CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU AND I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE THE.
THERE ARE NO MORE DADDY'S
SPEAKING MISTER MULLIN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
THE THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
THANK YOU TO MY WONDERFUL
COLLEAGUES AT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR MANY KIND THIS IS. AND
THOUGHTFULNESS ARE OVER THE PAST
COUPLE OF WEEKS AND SO MANY
MESSAGES SENT MY WAY WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL.
WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF DEBATE
ON A BILL SO WITH THAT. A LET ME
SIMPLY I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
AND ALSO WHY INDICATE THAT LIAM
AND LANDED ARE NOW THE NEWEST
FAITHFUL VIEWERS OF THE CAL
CHANNEL WITHOUT EYES FOR NIVEAU.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES SEVENTY
THREE NOSES ZERO.
MOVING BACK NOW TO ITEM THIRTY
THREE A. B. SIX TWENTY SIX MADAM
CLERK WILL YOU PLEASE READ THE
ITEM.
A CYNICAL SIX TWENTY SIX BY SOME
A MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA AND
OTHERS IN EXPLAIN TO THE
CALIFORNIA RETAIL FOOD CODE.
MR GARCIA YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
MEMBER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
AS WE ENTER INTO THE NEW YEAR
I'D LIKE YOU ALL TO REMEMBER THE
HOLIDAY SEASON WE JUST
CELEBRATED.
THERE'S A CUSTOM IN MY DISTRICT
AND PERHAPS IN MANY OF YOURS.
WHERE YOU HAVE THE MONEY IS
BEING SOLD IN AND AROUND THE
NEIGHBORHOOD?
AND OFTENTIMES WE REFER TO THE
PERSON. AND MOST TIMES IT'S A.
WOMAN AND WE FOR TOURISM AMALI
LADY.
DURING THE HOLIDAY SEASON.
IN MY DISTRICT WERE OVER ONE
QUARTER OF MY CONSTITUENTS ARE
CURRENTLY UNEMPLOYED.
THE HIGHEST RATE OF UNEMPLOYMENT
THAN ANYWHERE ELSE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE CELL OF HOMEMADE FOOD COULD
PROVIDE MEANINGFUL INCOME.
A COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE BUT ALSO
IN MANY THE COMMUNITIES.
LIKE YOURS.
FAMILIES WHO CANNOT AFFORD
CHRISTMAS PRESENTS A SCHOOL
SUPPLIES OR ASKING ME WHY. THEY
AREN'T ALLOWED TO SELL THEIR
FOOD.
KERN OPTIONS FOR SELLING FOOD
OUR SEVERITY PROHIBITIVE.
AND MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR MANY
COOKS TO INDEPENDENT BENEFIT
FROM THEIR LABOR AND SKILLS.
AS A RESULT THOUSANDS.
A POTENTIAL SMALL BUSINESS
ENTREPRENEURS
MISS OUT ON A CRITICAL INCOME
OPPORTUNITY. OR CHOOSE TO
OPERATE. UNDER THE TABLE WITHOUT
THE BENEFIT OF SAFETY GUIDELINES
OR OTHER RESOURCES TO PROTECT.
THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND WELL BEING
OF CALIFORNIANS.
THAT IS WHY I AM HONORED TODAY
TO STAND WITH MY CORE OUT THERE
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM FRESNO.
TO PRESENT EIGHT B. SIX TWENTY
SIX
THE HOMEMADE FOOD OPERATIONS AT.
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL IS TO
PROMOTE ECONOMIC EMPOWERMENT.
PARTICULARLY IN OUR MOST FORMAL
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
WHERE THE CELL OF HOMEMADE FOOD
IS ALREADY INCREDIBLY?
POPULAR.
I'D LIKE TO CLEAR UP TO BIG
MISCONCEPTIONS ABOUT THIS BILL.
A. B. SIX TWO SIX IS AN OPT IN
PROGRAM THAT WILL ONLY BE
ALLOWED IN COUNTIES. THAT DECIDE
THAT THIS IS AN ACTIVITY.
APPROPRIATE FOR THEM.
IF YOU ARE CONCERNED THAT A
COUNTY YOUR DISTRICT OPPOSES IT.
IT'S OKAY.
THEY ARE NOT REQUIRED.
TO ADOPT THIS PERMIT.
IF THEY CHOOSE NOT TO.
THE HEALTH OFFICERS AT EACH
COUNTY. ARE RELATED TO BUT
DIFFERENT
THEN THE ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS.
WHO ARE THE STAFF RESPONSIBLE
FOR PERMITTING FOOD FACILITIES?
AB SIX TWO SIX INCLUDES EVERY
AMENDMENT OFFERED BY THE
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH REGULATORS
WHICH WERE CLOSE TO TWELVE.
AMENDMENTS
P. EXPERTS.
SOME OF WHOM RECOGNIZE THAT
ENFORCEMENT TO TRY TO STAMP OUT
THIS ACTIVITY.
ONLY HURTS COMMUNITIES.
BUT THEY STILL CANNOT SUPPORT
THE BILL BECAUSE OF THEIR
POLITICAL RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
HELP OFFICERS AND COUNTIES.
COUNTIES THAT ADOPT AB SIX TWO
SIX WILL CREATE A PERMIT PROCESS
THAT WILL REQUIRE INSPECTIONS.
SAFE FOOD HANDLING TRAINING AND
OTHER SAFETY AND PUBLIC HEALTH
PRECAUTIONS.
THIS IS AN ADDITION TO THE
STATISTICS THAT SHOW THAT RATES
OF FOOD BORNE ILLNESS IN HOME
SETTINGS ARE A FRACTION OF THE
RATE OF ILLNESSES WE SEE. IN
COMMERCIAL SETTINGS.
FURTHER THIS BILL LIMITS THE
CELL. THE SCALE AND SALES TO
ENSURE IT IS A STEPPING STONE
TOWARD AND NOT. A REPLACEMENT UP
THE USE OF COMMERCIAL KITCHEN
SPACES WHEN APPROPRIATE AND
AVAILABLE TO CUTS.
IN SOME.
AB SIX TO SIX
IS LONG OVERDUE.
ADJUSTMENT TO OUR CODE THAT HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO HAVE A BIG
IMPACT ON THE ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS.
OF THE VERY COMMUNITIES THAT
NEED IT THE MOST.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO NO
VOTES I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I AM PROUD TO STAND IS A CO
AUTHOR OF AB SIX TWENTY SIX.
THIS BILL IS A POWERFUL ECONOMIC
TOOL TO HELP HOME COOKS LEGALLY
SELL FOOD FROM THEIR HOME
KITCHENS.
THIS BILL WILL PERMIT THE SALES
OF HOMEMADE FOODS AND PROVIDE
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS WITH THE
LEGAL AND SAFE PROCESS THROUGH
WHICH TO RUN THEIR
MICROENTERPRISE.
CONSUMERS AND ENTREPRENEURS
ALIKE WILL BENEFIT FROM THE
PUBLIC HEALTH REPORTING SYSTEM.
DELINEATED IN THIS BILL WHICH
WILL HELP TO ENSURE THAT THE
KITCHENS ARE INSPECTED AND
FOLLOWED PROPER PUBLIC HEALTH
PROTOCOLS. ENGENDERING
CONFIDENCE IN THE COOKS AND
SATISFIED CONSUMERS.
IN AREAS SUCH LIKE FRESNO THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW INDIVIDUALS IN
REMOTE AND RURAL REGIONS TO USE
THEIR SKILLS AND TALENTS.
TO LEGALLY SELL FOOD FROM THEIR
HOMES HELPING STAY AT HOME
PARENTS IMMIGRANTS FARMERS AND
TALENTED COOKS FROM ALL WALKS OF
LIFE.
SO HOMEMADE FOOD AS A MEANS FOR
EXPORT ECONOMIC UPWARD MOBILITY.
I WANTED TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS BILL I KNOW HE AND I BOTH
HAVE NOT MISSED TOO MANY
HOMEMADE THE MULLIS.
BUT WE MUST LOOK TO THE FACT
THAT THIS PERMITTING PROCESS IN
AB SIX TWENTY SIX WILL INCREASE
THE CONFIDENCE OF THE
ENTREPRENEURS AND THE CONSUMERS.
HELPING SET THEM ON A TRACK OF
SUCCESS.
I HOPE YOU'LL JOIN ME TODAY
INSUPPORTING THE HOMEMADE FOOD
OPERATIONS ACT I URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE OR ACCEPT THAT AS
YOUR CLOTHES.
COLLEAGUES SEVERAL YEARS AGO
THERE WAS A DEBATE.
WITH REGARD TO THE FOOT TRUCKS
THAT WE SEE IN AND AROUND THE
CAPITAL AND PERHAPS IN YOUR
DISTRICTS WHERE WE SEE. FOOD
TRUCK FESTIVALS AND THERE WAS A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF PUSH BACK.
THAT YOU KNOW THEY COULD BE
HARMFUL HURTFUL TO THE PUBLIC
CAL.
AND WELL BEING OF YOU KNOW THOSE
WHO WOULD PATRONIZE THESE
PARTICULAR FOOD TRUCKS AND. AND
AND I THINK THAT'S
BEEN NO DEMYSTIFY. YOU KNOW
ARGUMENT SEVERAL YEARS AGO THERE
WAS DE COLLEGE FOOD INDUSTRY
BILL.
THAT AS OPENED UP OPPORTUNITIES
FOR MANY INDIVIDUALS TO
ESTABLISH THESE MICRO
ENTERPRISES.
BUSINESSES AND HAS SUPPORTED
COMMUNITIES LIKE YOURS AND MINE.
ECONOMICALLY AND DIE IN HERE WE
ARE TODAY THE SKY HASN'T FALLEN.
SO WE HAVE THIS BILL THAT BUILDS
ON THOSE EFFORTS THAT ULTIMATELY
DOES AS I MENTIONED THREE THINGS
THAT PROTECTS THE PUBLIC CAL.
OF PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA.
IT NUMBER TO IT FOCUSES ON
ECONOMIC EMPOWERMENT.
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE LIMITED BUT
CAN USE THEIR SKILL SETS.
APPLY THEM IN A WAY IN WHICH
THEY CAN PROVIDING FOOD GOOD A
SERVICE.
AND THEN THE THIRD.
THAT I'M NOT MENTION IS IT
DECRIMINALIZE THE SOMETHING.
THAT ALREADY IS HAPPENING.
YOU MAY HAVE READ OR HEARD OF A
STORY OF A YOUNG WOMAN DOWN THE
STREET IN THE COUNTY. NEXT DOOR
WHERE SHE WAS ARRESTED FOR
SELLING SEMICHA.
AND PROSECUTED BY THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY.
NOW I MEAN I THINK THAT WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE IS VERY
PRAGMATIC IN.
COMMONSENSE APPROACH TO MAKING
SURE THAT ALL OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH REGULATIONS AND
INSPECTIONS ARE PLACE.
IN ORDER TO AGAIN.
ESTABLISH THESE MICRO
ENTERPRISES IN OUR COMMUNITIES
PROTECT THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
ONCE AGAIN DECRIMINALIZE
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS ALREADY
IN OUR COMMUNITIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU WITHOUT.
MADAM CLERK WILL YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES.
EYES FIFTY NINE NO ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM THIRTY FOUR A.
B. NINE HUNDRED. MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ THE ITEM. AND SOME
PEOPLE NINE HUNDRED BY SOME THE
MEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE CRIME
VICTIMS MAKING APPROPRIATION
THERE FOR.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ FLETCHER
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB NINE
HUNDRED WILL HELP VICTIMS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING REBUILD THEIR
LIVES BY ALLOWING THE CALIFORNIA
VICTIM COMPENSATION BOARD TO
COMPENSATE THEM. FOR LOSS OF
INCOME DURING THE CRIME OF
TRAFFICKING.
WE ALL NO THAT HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AS A BIG PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA
IN FACT OVER A QUARTER OF
FEDERAL HUMAN TRAFFICKING CASES
ARE. BASED HERE.
ONE ONCE VICTIMS HAVE ESCAPED
THEY MUST CONFRONT THE REALITIES
OF NEEDING HOUSING BASIC DAILY
NECESSITIES AND TREATMENT FOR
MEDICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES.
HOWEVER WHILE THE PERSON WAS HIT
BY A CAR IN A DRUNK DRIVING CASE
AND CAN'T WORK CAN RECEIVE
COMPENSATION FOR LOST INCOME.
THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING VICTIM
WHOSE PROMISED WAGES WERE NEVER
RECEIVED WHILE THEY LABORED AND
WAS DEPRIVED OPPORTUNITY TO EARN
LEGAL WAGES CANNOT CURRENTLY BE
COMPENSATED FOR LOST INCOME.
THE WAY CURRENT REGULATIONS ARE
WRITTEN SIMPLY DO NOT
ACKNOWLEDGE THIS KIND OF
CIRCUMSTANCE FOR COMPENSATION.
AB NINE HUNDRED WOULD FIX THIS
INEQUITY AND ELP VICTIMS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING GET BACK ON
THEIR FEET BY EXPANDING THEIR
ELIGIBILITY TO RECEIVE
COMPENSATION.
FOR ECONOMIC LOSSES INCURRED IS
A DIRECT RESULT OF THERE BEING
TRAFFICKED THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ.
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE RIGHT
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINE
HUNDRED. WE KNOW THE CRIME OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING IS PREVALENT.
IT LEAVES SURVIVORS WITH
PHYSICAL EMOTIONAL AND MENTAL
TRAUMA.
COMPENSATION IS NECESSARY TO
ENSURE THAT SURVIVORS OF THIS
HORRIBLE CRIME HAVE STABILITY TO
GET BACK ON THEIR FEET.
AB NINE HUNDRED ONE SURE
SURVIVORS CAN MOVE FORWARD AND
HE'LL. RESPECT ASK FOR MY VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
JUST ASK YOUR ABOUT THANK YOU
THANK YOU ALL DEBATE HAVING
CEASED MADAM CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE A TALLY THE VOTES I SEVENTY
TWO NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM THIRTY FIVE A.
B. THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE MADAM
CLERK PLEASE READ THE ITEM.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE BY SOMETHING MEMBER KANSEN
CHU EXPLAINED A TRANSPORTATION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TO YOUR
RECOGNIZED SACRAMENTO SPEAKER
THE AB WAS CERTAIN NINETY FIVE
IS A CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY CLEAN UP
BILL. THAT THIS BILL WOULD
DIRECTED CALTRANS TO THE WORK
WAS TO LOCAL JURISDICTION TO
DEVELOP A PLAN. TO ADDRESS THE A
LITTER SONORA FREEWAY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE SIX IF SEVEN
MILLION DOLLAR THAT WE SPEND
EVERY YEAR. WHAT THE MORE
EFFECTIVE NO LOVE ONE OF THE?
BUT SUGGESTION GUY HOW WE'RE
TALKING WITH THE CALTRANS IS TO
COPY OF THE CITY SAN JOSE. A
APPROACH TO THIS PROBLEM A DAISY
THE PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN SAN JOSE
TO RESIDENT CAN DOWNLOAD A FREE.
AB OWN DARED A SMARTPHONE TO
TAKE A PICTURE AND SEND THAT TO
DO CALTRANS OF. OF A CENTRAL
LOCATION SO WAY TO A ADDRESSES
TO THEIR
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MEMBERS I MUST A RISE IN
OPPOSITION. TO THIS MEASURE.
OUT OF CONCERN FOR MY RURAL
AREAS.
IT'S ONE THING TO SAY WE'RE
GOING TO REALLOCATE AND PUSH
TOWARDS THE MORE HIGHER DANCE.
TRAFFIC AREAS BUT LET'S BE REAL
THAT MEANS THE LOWER TRAFFIC
AREAS AND OUR RURAL AREAS ARE
GOING TO BE AFFECTED.
NOW. WHEN I FIRST GOT UP TO
SACRAMENTO I AUTHORED IF YOU SO
LEGISLATION AB ONE FORTY FOUR.
WHICH WENT AFTER DUMPING ON
PRIVATE PROPERTY.
BECAUSE AND WE ACTUALLY GOT ALL
THE WAY TO THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
IN ANY VETO IT.
NOW I IT TALK TO THE AUTHOR
EARLY ON IN THE PROCESS ABOUT
MAYBE LOOKING AT WHAT WE DID
WITH THAT. GOING AFTER THE
SERIAL DUMPERS IN AND USING THE
MONEY THAT WE WOULD CHARGE THEM.
FOR COMMITTEE KNOW CRIME AND
ACTUALLY USE THAT FOR THE
PURPOSES OF CLEANING UP THE
TRASH CLEANING UP THE LITTER
CLEANING UP THE GRAFFITI. AND
USE THAT AS A FUNDING FORMULA
CLEARLY YOU WANT A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION HERE.
INSTEAD WOULD RATHER PULL THE
MONEY FROM OUR MORE RURAL AREAS.
I THINK THERE'S DEFINITELY
BETTER WAYS TO DO THIS.
I THINK WE CAN LOOK AT IT
DIFFERENTLY AND I ASK FOR A NO
VOTE AND LET'S GO BACK TO THE
DRAWING BOARD TO GET THIS RIGHT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
WOULD YOU LIKE TO RESPOND TO
CLOSE.
OH SIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH A.
AGAIN AND WHAT WE WOULD BE ABLE
TO WORK OUT THAT THIS IS JUST
TOO DIRECTED CALTRANS TO DEVELOP
A PLAN TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE. OF
THE REASON THAT WE WILL USE THAT
TRAFFIC.
IS BECAUSE THOSE TWO BREEDS ARE
NOT ONLY A A BIT AND I SWORE TO
MANY OFF TO COMMUTE HER BODY
ALSO A AND INCREASED US SAFETY
HAZARD. AND AND ALSO LEAD
POLLUTION POLLUTION TO WATER
WAVES AND A MARINE HABITAT. OF
BUT DID IT AGAIN WILL CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE CALTRANS
TO DEVELOP A PLAN THAT WAS
ACTUALLY A DATA DRIVEN.
VOIGTS SO WE CAN HAVE A BETTER
BAND FOR OUR OF BOX AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SIXTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
I ASK FOR YOUR I WILL.
THANK YOU. MADAM CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES.
EYES FIFTY FOUR ELEVEN SNOW THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO ITEM THIRTY SIX AB
FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO MADAM CLERK
WILL YOU PLEASE READ THE ITEM.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN FIFTY TWO
BY SOMEONE NUMBER QUIRK SILVA
AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. AB FIFTEEN FIFTY TO
ENCOURAGED ENCOURAGES PUBLIC
UTILITIES TO PROMPTLY PAY
SUPPLIERS WHO HAVE SUBMITTED
TIMELY INVALID INVOICES AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN REGULATED PUBLIC
UTILITIES EXPEND IN NINE POINT
SEVEN BILLION THROUGH THE
SUPPLIER DIVERSITY NETWORK. OVER
THE YEARS THESE CONTRACTS HAVE
PLAYED AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN
EXPANDING THE POOL OF POTENTIAL.
BIDDERS AND PROVIDED REVENUE TO
NEW AND EMERGING BUSINESSES THE
OVERALL SUCCESS OF THE SUPPLIER
DIVERSITY PROGRAM CAN HOWEVER BE
UNDERMINE WHEN SUPPLIERS ARE NOT
PAID IN A TIMELY FASHION.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE ESTABLISHING
THE EXACT PROCESS FOR ENSURING
TIMELY PAYMENTS ARE MADE. THAT
ARE MADE REQUIRES EXTENDED
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN INTERESTED
PARTIES MEMBERS THIS BILL IS AN
ATTEMPT TO MAKE SURE THAT SOME
OF OUR BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
ALREADY PROVIDED SERVICES THAT
THEY GET PAID ON TIME. IT'S
SIMPLY A BILL THAT MAKE SURE
WHEN SOMEBODY HAS PROVIDED
SERVICE THEY'RE PAID WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO DEBATER DISCUSSION THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLER TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS ARE PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL.
ON FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX.
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT BY
MISTER JONES SAWYER COOK POSTS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH IS ABOUT
.
MISTER JONES SAWYER.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTES.
EYES TWENTY SIX.
NOS TWENTY SIX.
THAT MEASURE FAILS.
I WAS BACK IN FILE ORDER.
WE OUR AT FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY SEVEN.
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY THREE
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN SIXTY
THREE BY FAMILY MEMBER CRISTINA
GARCIA AND ACTUALLY THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE.
IS GARCIA. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I MEMBERS TEARS AGO WE
PASSED AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY
THIRTY WHICH REALLOCATED IF HE
ALREADY IMPOSED ON ALL HER CAR
BATTERIES. TO FUND THE CLEANUP
OF CONTAMINATION COSTS BY LEAD
BATTERIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
FOR EXAMPLE EXCITED MY BACKYARD.
SINCE BEING SIGNED INTO LAW THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
WORKING ON REGULATIONS TO
IMPLEMENT THE BILL.
TECHNICAL PROBLEMS IDENTIFIED IN
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THOSE
PROBLEMS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CO.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
ON THE ITEM CLERK LOVE IN THE
ROLE. ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTES.
I SIXTY THREE.
NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FIVE ITEM THIRTY EIGHT.
AB NINE EIGHTY SIX CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE EIGHTY SIX BY
SOME A NUMBER GALLAGHER AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE FISH AND
WILDLIFE.
STERN GALLAGHER PART THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AND
PLEASE A PRESENT AB NINE EIGHTY
SIX WHICH INVOLVES.
A FEW ISSUES ARE CLOSE TO MY
HEART HUNTING FISHING. AND
VETERANS.
A THIS BILL WOULD DISCOUNT
FISHING AND HUNTING LICENCES FOR
CALIFORNIA VETERANS.
AND REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
TO PROVIDE SPORTS FISHING
LICENSES THAT ARE VALID FOR
TWELVE. CONSECUTIVE MONTHS SO
FOR THOSE YOU HER FISHERMEN.
FISHER WOMEN. AYE YOU WOULD
APPRECIATE THE YOU CAN GET A
TWELVE MONTH. LICENSE NOW NOT
JUST.
ACCOUNTING YOUR LICENSE.
I HAVE ADDITIONALLY AB EIGHT AB
NINETY SIX RECOGNIZE THE
SACRIFICES OF CALIFORNIA SERVICE
MEN AND WOMEN. BY DISCOUNTING
THE ANNUAL AND LIFETIME LICENCES
BY TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. FOR
HONORABLY DISCHARGED VETERANS
AB NINETY SIX AS NO OPPOSITION
IS RECEIVE UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
THIS FALL. THUS FAR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
THE.
THANK YOU MISS GALLAGHER.
SEE KNOW DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. CLERK WILL OF THE
ROLE.
SORRY TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE A ROLL AND TELL YOU WHAT I
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES
RECOGNIZE FROM MY DESK IN THE
WHERE THE CHAMBER MISTER MEDIA.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY.
IT IS MY.
HUGE HONOR.
TO INTRODUCE SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T
NEED AN INTRODUCTION.
AND BEFORE I INTRODUCE. SHE IS
HERE WITH PROFESSOR. AT TEN
HERNANDEZ FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
TEXAS EL PASO. TO COMMEMORATE
THE ANNIVERSARY THAT WE
COMMEMORATED EARLIER IN THE DAY
THE PLAIN RACK LOS GATOS.
SO WITH THAT IT IS AGAIN MY
PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE SOMEONE
WHO IS VERY SPECIAL IN MY OWN
LIFE. AND MY GROWING UP.
AND WHAT WE HOLD DEAR. AS
CALIFORNIA.
SHE IS SUNG. THOSE SONGS AND SHE
HAS MADE THE MARCHERS WITH
EVERYONE IN OUR HISTORY. THE
UNITED STATES WEATHER WAS MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR.
IN THE SOUTH. OR CESA CHAVEZ AND
THE LOTUS WHAT THAT HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO IT IS MY
PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE JOAN BAEZ.
WE.
MISTER SPEAKER.
WE'VE HAD.
MANY PEOPLE ON THE FLOOR.
I I REMEMBER WHEN WE HAD A.
THE DALAI LAMA. HERE. AND I I
THINK THAT TODAY IS JUST A
SPECIAL. TODAY TO HAVE A JOAN
BAEZ HERE WITH US TODAY.
MISSED BY US.
THANK YOU VERY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
MS BAEZ MADE ARRESTS THE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OUT JUST VERY
BRIEFLY WHAT I'M HERE FOR IS TO.
BASICALLY CELEBRATE THE FACT
THAT THE.
ANONYMOUS PEOPLE WENT DOWN THE
AIRPLANE. SEVENTY YEARS AGO
BUNCH OF MEXICAN WORKERS WERE
GIVEN NO NAMES WHEN THERE PRESS
ANNOUNCEDTHAT THIS PLANE HAD
GONE UP IN FLAMES. AND THEY WERE
CALLED DEPORTEES PERIOD. AND SO
FOR.
MANY MANY MANY YEARS TIM HERE
RESEARCHED TO TRY AND FIND THE
PEOPLE TO FIND THEIR RELATIVES
TO GIVE THEM. THEIR DIGNITY AND
SOME KIND OF PEACE OF MIND AND
DID FOUND FIND EVERY ONE OF THEM
AND TODAY WE HAD MEMBERS OF
THOSE FAMILIES.
HERE.
AT THE LEGISLATURE SO.
SO IT'S A BIG DAY FOR US AND
THE IT'S A BIG DAY AND THIS
PARTICULAR TIME IN OUR HISTORY
AS WELL. TO BE HONORING
OF THE MEXICAN LATINO LATINA
FACTORS. THANK YOU
MEMBERS WE STILL HAVE BUSINESS
BEFORE THE HOUSE.
MEMBERS.
WE STILL HAVE BUSINESS BEFORE
THE HOUSE.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY TWO.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE GOING BE
TAKING UP.
A. B..
FOURTEEN NINETEEN BY DOCTOR
QUIRK THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME LEGAL FOURTEEN NINETEEN BY
SOME THE MEMBER QUIRK ACTUALLY
PESTICIDES.
DOCTOR QUIRK.
AB FOURTEEN NINETEEN WILL
PROVIDE THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION AUTHORITY
TO ENFORCE.
THE STATE'S PESTICIDE USE LAW
FOR SERIOUS VIOLATIONS.
RECENTLY THERE'S BEEN AN
ALARMING NUMBER OF SERIOUS CASES
OF PESTICIDE DRIFT.
THEY HAVE NEGATIVELY IMPACTED
YOU MEN AND WILDLIFE FELL.
CROSS JURISDICTION VIOLATIONS
HAVE PROVEN DIFFICULT TO ENFORCE
BECAUSE COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS HAVE LIMITED
AUTHORITY DECIDE FOR VIOLATIONS
THAT EXTEND OUTSIDE THE
BOUNDARIES.
FURTHER OF ADDING TO THE
DIFFICULTY OF ENFORCEMENT
IS IT THE MAXIMUM PENALTY THAT
CAN BE. LEVIED FOR VIOLATIONS
HAS NOT INCREASED FIFTEEN YEARS.
MY BILL STRENGTHENS
STRENGTHENS OUR PESTICIDE USE
LAW IN THE FOLLOWING WAYS.
IT GIVES THE DEPARTMENT MORE
ADMINISTRATIVE AUTHORITY TO TAKE
ENFORCEMENT ACTION AGAINST
SERIOUS CASES.
SECOND IT ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT
TO LEVY A FINE OF UP TO TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
VIOLATION. AND THIRD ALLOWS
COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS REFER CASES SUCH
AS WHEN THERE'S A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST TO THE DEPARTMENT.
THANK YOU.
THANK A DUCT WORK MISTER DALI.
THEY YEARS IS BIGGER MEMBERS I
RISE IN OPPOSITION THIS BILL I
ACTUALLY.
I'M ON THE TALKIES COMMITTEE OR
WAS ON THE TOXIC COMMITTEE I
ALSO HAVE AN APPLICATORS PERMIT
AND THIS GIVES A LOT OF CONTROL
TO COUNTY. THE AG COMMISSIONERS
WHO ARE NOT VERSED IN LAW. AND
OTHER CAN BE ACCUSATIONS AND
QUITE FRANKLY THIS IS AN OVER
REACH A BIG OVERREACH A I
BELIEVE BY THE DPR FOLKS SO I. A
STRONGLY STRONGLY ASK FOR A NO
VOTE ON THIS BILL.
MISTER DALLI SEEN NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION.
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM DOCTOR
QUIRK YOU MAY CLOSE YES OUR
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE CONTROL
HAS THE EXPERTISE TO DO THIS.
OFTEN THE.
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS DO
NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES NECESSARY
TO PURSUE THESE CASES.
AND IN CASES WHERE THERE ARE.
.
IMPACTS ON HUMAN HEALTH.
AND ON.
CONTAMINATION OF WATER SOURCES
AND SUCH IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT WE GET. THE MAXIMUM AMOUNT
OF ENFORCEMENT THANK YOU.
I REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
WITH THAT CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
DOCTOR QUIRK MOVES A CALL
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A CONSENT
CALENDAR.
IS ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SOME LEGAL FIFTEEN TWENTY SIX BY
SOMEONE MEMBER KALRA ACTUALLY
THE CIVIL ACTIONS.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
CALENDAR MEMBERS THIS IS CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS WHO WISH TO VOTE
THIS
SAN.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE.
TALLY THE VOTE EYES SEVENTY TWO.
NO ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SEVENTY NINE. EYES SEVENTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO AT SOME LEVEL SIX
SIXTY FOUR I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO
SUM LEGAL AID ON NINE I SEVENTY
TWO NO ZERO SUM LEGAL EIGHT
EIGHTY EIGHT. I SEVENTY TWO NO
ZERO CYCLE TEN THIRTEEN EYES
SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO UNABLE
TWELVE EIGHTY NINE.
I SEVENTY TWO THOSE ZERO SUM
LEGAL FIFTEEN THIRTY ONE I
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE I SEVENTY
TWO NO ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN NINETY SIX BY SEVENTY
TWO NO ZERO AND ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE.
I SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
.
IT WAS A BRIEF ANNOUNCEMENT THIS
PAST SATURDAY WAS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAISES BIRTHDAY ASSEMBLY
WILL RAISE IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER SWISHER HAPPY FOR.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO.
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A CHAIRMAN IN MEMORY.
AND I'D ASK THAT MEMBERS PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS.
SO YOUR COLLEAGUES MAY ADJOURN.
IN THE MEMORY.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH MR.
ESTHER BLOOM.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
AND GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION.
TO MR BLOW MISTER BLOOM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY THANK YOU MEMBERS SO I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
HARRY PREGGERS AND WHO SERVED
WITH GREAT DISTINCTION ON THE U.
S. NINTH CIRCUIT COURT OF
APPEALS. FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS
BEFORE PASSING AWAY DURING OUR
BREAK ON NOVEMBER TWENTY FIFTH
AT THE AGE OF NINETY FOUR.
BORN ON OCTOBER THIRTEENTH
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE TO JEWISH
IMMIGRANTS FROM EASTERN EUROPE
PREGGERS AND GREW UP IN EAST LA
AND SERVED AS A MARINE IN WORLD
WAR TWO.
HE RECEIVED AS UNDERGRADUATE
DEGREE FROM UCLA AND HIS JD FROM
UC BERKELEY. WAS APPOINTED TO
THE NINTH CIRCUIT COURT OF
APPEALS IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE.
WHERE HE BUILT A LEGACY AS ONE
OF THE MOST PROGRESSIVE JUDGES
IN THE COUNTRY?
HIS RULINGS AND DISSENSIONS
FREQUENTLY STIRRED CONTROVERSY.
AND DEFIED JUDICIAL PRECEDENT IN
ADDITION TO FREQUENTLY
DISSENTING IN RULINGS THAT
UPHELD LIFE SENTENCES AND
REFUSING TO FOLLOW PRECEDENT UP
HOLDING CALIFORNIA'S THREE
STRIKES LAW. PRIGOGINE ONCE
ORDERED A HOLD ON THE EXECUTION
OF AN INDIVIDUAL ALREADY
STRAPPED INSIDE THE GAS CHAMBER.
PERSON WAS PASSIONATE ABOUT
FIGHTING ON BEHALF OF THE POOR
IN LOS ANGELES AND WAS OFTEN
DESCRIBED AS A JUDICIAL
ACTIVIST.
HE WANTS HALTED CONSTRUCTION OF
INTERSTATE EXPRESSWAY IN SOUTH
LOS ANGELES ARGUING THAT IT
WOULD HAVE UPROOTED LOW INCOME
FAMILIES FROM THEIR HOMES.
AND HE LATER FORCED THE PROJECT
TO PROVIDE HOUSING AND JOBS TO
THOUSANDS OF IMPACTED
INDIVIDUALS.
WITH THE ONE OH FIVE FREEWAY.
PRAGER SINCE SAW HIS JUDGE SAID
AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE AND
HELP PEOPLE ANY DID SO NOT ONLY
IN HIS PROFESSIONAL LIFE BUT
ALSO HIS PERSONAL.
A VETERAN HIMSELF PRAGER SIN WAS
COMMITTED TO THE WELL BEING OF
VETERANS AND ALSO HELPED
ESTABLISH SEVERAL HOMELESS
SHELTERS IN LOS ANGELES.
PREGGERS AND DESCRIBED HIS
CONSCIENCE AS A PRODUCT OF THE
TEN COMMANDMENTS THE BILL OF
RIGHTS THE BOY SCOUT OATH. AND
THE MARINECORPS HIM.
AND ONCE FAMOUSLY SAID THAT IF
FORCED TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
FOLLOWING HIS CONSCIENCE OR THE
LAW. HE WOULD CHOOSE HIS
CONSCIENCE.
THE WIDELY REVIEWED IT WIDELY
VIEWED AS A LIBERAL PREGGERS AND
ALSO STRONGLY BELIEVED IN
LIMITING THE POWER OF
GOVERNMENT.
HE PASSED AWAY IN HIS WOODLAND
HILLS.
HOME THIS PAST NOVEMBER IN THE
PRESENCE OF FAMILY AND IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE DAUGHTER
SIBLINGS FOUR GRANDCHILDREN AND
TWO GREAT GRANDCHILDREN.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM WHEN YOU
HAVE AN ADDITIONAL ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY I DO THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I ALSO RISE TO ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF FORMER U. S.
SENATOR. JOHN TINY WHO PASSED
AWAY ON JANUARY TWELFTH FROM
PROSTATE CANCER.
TONY WAS BORN ON JUNE TWENTY SIX
NINETEEN THIRTY FOUR IN NEW YORK
CITY THE SON OF FORMER BOXING
HEAVYWEIGHT CHAMP. GENE TUNNEY
AND CARNEGIE STEEL FORTUNE
HEIRESS POLLY LOUDER.
HE GREW UP IN CONNECTICUT
ATTENDED YALE UNIVERSITY WHERE
HE LATER STUDIED INTERNATIONAL
LAW THE HAGUE AND RECEIVED HIS
JURIS DOCTOR FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF VIRGINIA.
TONY PRACTICED LAW IN NEW YORK
PRIOR TO RUNNING FOR ELECTED
OFFICE WHICH SHE RETURNED TO
AFTER THE END OF A SHORT LIVED.
POLITICAL CAREER.
AFTER SERVING IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES FOR THREE TERMS
FROM NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT.
TONY RAN FOR THE U. S. SENATE IN
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES AND AT
THE AGE OF THIRTY SIX BECAME THE
YOUNGEST PERSON TO EVER BE
ELECTED TO THE SENATE.
A RISING POLITICAL STAR HIS RACE
WAS CLOSELY WATCHED AND EVEN
INSPIRED THE ROBERT REDFORD FILM
THE CANDIDATE.
DURING HIS TIME IN THE SENATE HE
HELPED EXPAND THE VOTING RIGHTS
ACT AND EXTENDED THE NOISE
POLLUTION CONTROL ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO.
HOWEVER IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX
AFTER SURVIVING A PRIMARY
CHALLENGE BY TOM HAYDEN TWENTY
LOST HIS SEAT TO REPUBLICAN AND
THEN CSU PRESIDENT. SI HAYAKAWA.
TONY NEVER RETURN TO POLITICS
AFTER HIS LOSS.
AND PRACTICED LAW AFTER LEAVING
OFFICE BECOMING A PARTNER IN THE
FIRM OF MANATT PHELPS ROTHENBERG
AND TONI.
HE REMAINED ACTIVE ON VARIOUS
BOARDS AND WAS INVOLVED IN CIVIC
AND CULTURAL PROGRAMS.
HE LOVES THE OUTDOORS AND HIS
FAVORITE ACTIVITIES INCLUDED
SKIING FLY FISHING HIKING AND
TRAVELING WITH HIS WIFE.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
AS BROTHER TWO SONS A DAUGHTER
TWO STEPCHILDREN AND THREE AGAIN
GRANDCHILDREN AND ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM.
THIS BAKER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
REMEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY TO JOIN IN THE
MEMORY OF.
MARILYN BRADLEE.
RESIDENT OF SAN RAMON WHO PASSED
AWAY ON DECEMBER TWENTIETH AFTER
A LONG BATTLE WITH CANCER.
TIPPING KEEP IT TOGETHER FOR
THIS ONE.
THOSE OF US WHO KNEW MARILYN
KNEW HER AS MAYOR BRADLEY.
SHE WAS BORN IN NINETEEN THIRTY
NINE TO ZITA AND ROBERT MCCUE IN
DENVER COLORADO.
SHE ATTENDED SCHOOL AT ST MARY'S
ACADEMY IN ENGLEWOOD COLORADO.
AND LATER WENT ON TO STUDY AT
THE SAN FRANCISCO COLLEGE FOR
WOMEN.
AFTER GRADUATING.
SHE FELL IN LOVE WITH A
WONDERFUL DEVOTED MAN AND HAS
BEEN.
MARTIN BRADLEY.
AND THEY HAVE A MARRIAGE
SPENDING THIRTY TWO YEARS.
THERE WERE A LOVING COUPLE.
THEY MOVED TO BERKELEY AND LATER
TOOK UP PERMANENT RESIDENCE
RIGHT THE HEART OF ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT SIXTEEN IN SAN RAMON.
MOST OF MAYORS WORKING CAREER.
WAS EMBLEMATIC OF ONE OF HER
GREAT TRACE WHERE SHE WAS
DEDICATED AND PASSIONATE AND
THOROUGH AND ANYTHING SHE DID.
ANYTHING SHE UNDERTOOK.
SHE WORKED AT GILLINGHAM
CONSTRUCTION IN PLEASANTON
CALIFORNIA THROUGHOUT HER
CAREER.
AND SHE WAS AN ADMIN UP SHE WAS
AN ADMINISTRATIVE ASSISTANT IN
THE INDUSTRIAL DIVISION.
SHE LATER RETIRED IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE.
AND WHEN SHE DID SHE WENT FULL
BORE INTO BEING A GRANDPARENT.
SHE WAS KNOWN FOR ATTENDING
EVERY SINGLE ONE OR JUST ABOUT
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF HER FOUR
GRANDCHILDREN SCHOOL EVENTS.
AND ACTIVITIES
AND PROGRAMS I KNOW THIS BECAUSE
WHENEVER I ASKED HER DID SHE CAN
JOIN US IT'S SOMETHING THE ONE
TIME SHE WOULDN'T COME
SHE WOULD SAY. MY GRANDKIDS HAVE
AN EVENT AND I'M GONNA BE THERE.
SHE WAS VERY VERY ACTIVE IN
THEIR SCHOOLS AND PUBLIC
FUNCTIONS AND POLITICAL GROUPS
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY.
SHE SERVED AS CO PRESIDENT OF
THE BLACK HAWK REPUBLICAN WOMEN
FEDERATED GROUP.
AND WAS VOTED IS THE GROUPS
WOMEN OF THE DECADE AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN.
AND THAT'S HOW I CAME TO KNOW
MAYOR BRADLEY ABOUT TEN YEARS
AGO.
WHEN I WAS JUST STARTING TO
THINK GOSH I WANNA GET MORE
POLITICALLY INVOLVED SO I WENT
TO A LOCAL FEDERATED GROUP.
IT WAS MARRIAGE CHAPTER.
AND DASH SHOES WHEN THOSE FOLKS
THAT.
KNOWS THAT YOU DON'T KNOW
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM SO SHE'S
GONNA MAKE SURE TO GREET YOU AND
FIND YOU AND HELP INTRODUCE YOU
TO EVERYONE THERE.
AND THOSE FOLKS OVER THE YEARS
HAVE LATER BECOME GREAT FRIENDS
ALL OF WHOM NUMERIC BRADLEY.
AND IT WAS JUST A TRADE OF HERS
TO MAKE SURE THAT SHE SUPPORTED
OTHERS WHEN SHE AND MARTIN WOULD
SIT AND BE AT THE CHECK IN DESK.
THAT ANY EVENTS AT THE CLUB HAD
YOU ALWAYS KNEW SHE WAS GOING
AGREED WITH A SMILE. AND THEY IT
WAS GONNA BE A GOOD EVENT.
AND I JUST THE PERFECT WAY TO
START ANY KIND OF PROGRAMMER
EVENT AND SHE WAS JUST
COMPLETELY DEDICATED.
SHE CAME TO EVERY CONVENTION
EVERY PROGRAM THAT OUR LOCAL
PARTY WOULD HAVE IN STATEWIDE
CONVENTIONS AND WAS KNOWN AS OF
FOR BYOB. BRING YOUR OWN BUBBLY.
AND OUT WAS VERY FUN AND SHARING
IT WITH EVERYONE ELSE'S THE
CONVENTION HOURS WHEN ON.
GENEROUS GENEROUS OPEN HEART.
I THERE ARE TIMES WHEN SHE FIND
OUT OF SOME COLLEGE STUDENT OR
SOME VOLUNTEER NEEDED
TRANSPORTATION TO GET SOMEWHERE
IN SHOULD SHE HAVE AN EXTRA
TRUCK SHOULD SAY HERE YOU CAN
BORROW MY TRUCK.
OF THE NEEDED NEXT TO PLACE TO
STAY SHE MAKE HER HOME
AVAILABLE.
AND NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE DO THAT.
SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER LOVING.
HUSBAND MARTIN HER TWO CHILDREN.
KATHLEEN PERRY AND ROBERT MASER.
AND A BEAUTIFUL GRANDCHILDREN
KIMBERLY BROADLY LAUREN AND
MICHAEL.
IT'S APPROPRIATE THAT SHE WAS
BORN ON VALENTINE'S DAY BECAUSE
SHE WAS VERY MUCH FULL OF LOVE.
AND I HAVE A PICTURE HERE. AND I
JUST SAY DEAR SWEET. SWEET
MANNER.
WE LOVE YOU. GOD BLESS YOU AND
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES FOR
ADJOURNING IN HER MEMORY TODAY.
HE WAS BAKER.
SOMERS HOOCHIE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF A DEAR.
FRIEND OF MINE THERESA BIRD.
IF TORRANCE.
THERESA BIRD.
PROUD DEMOCRAT.
SHE WAS ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE.
THAT WOULD ALWAYS
SHOW UP.
WHENEVER WE HAD A PHONE BANK
GOING.
THERESA.
HAD DEDICATED HER ENTIRE LIFE
TO MAKING A DIFFERENCE SHE WAS
INSPIRED.
BY.
JUST LIKE MANY.
FOLKS OF HER GENERATION SHE WAS
INSPIRED BY JOHN F. KENNEDY.
TO GET INVOLVED.
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN OUR
WORLD.
THERESA BIRD ONE ON.
TO.
SERVE IN MANY CAPACITIES
LOCAL STATE AND NATIONAL.
SHE WORKED FOR GOVERNOR JERRY
BROWN. IN ITS FIRST.
STAND AS THE GOVERNOR OUR STATE.
AS A MANAGER OF THE LOS ANGELES
DISTRICT OFFICE FOR GOVERNOR
BROWN.
THERE'S A FUNNY STORY.
WHEN GOVERNOR BROWN CAME INTO MY
CAMPAIGN OFFICE.
TO SUPPORT MY CAMPAIGN IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN.
WE.
WITH SECOND A LOT OF HANDS AND
MANY SAW THERESA.
AND THEN HE SAID.
TO RESERVE. YOUR STILL ALIVE.
THAT'S OUR GOVERNOR EXPRESSING
HIS.
AFFECTION FOR THERESA BIRD.
THERESA ALSO WORK FOR THIRTEEN
YEARS.
FOR THE LATE STATE SENATOR RALPH
GILLES.
SHE WAS A FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
SOUTH BAY DEMOCRATIC CLUB THE
SERVE.
FOR THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
AT THE NATIONAL STATE COUNTY
LOCAL LEVELS FOR OVER FIFTY
YEARS.
I JUST WANT TO THANK TERESA.
FOR YOUR MANY YEARS OF ACTIVISM.
YOU MADE A DIFFERENCE
A BIG DIFFERENCE IN MY LIFE.
AND IN THE LIVES OF SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS
I ASK.
THAT THE STATE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED IN HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SUJI.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ONE ITEM THAT IS
ON CALL
SO I AM PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL.
ON FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO THIS AB
FOURTEEN NINETEEN THE CORPORAL
POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO WISH TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VETERANS OUT OF THE
TYR QUIRK WHAT'S YOUR PLEASURE.
CLOSE ROLE.
CLOSE ROLE TELL THE VOTE.
EYES THIRTY FOUR KNOWS TWENTY
SIX THAT MEASURE FAILS.
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS TUESDAY JANUARY
THIRTIETH CHECK IN THE SESSION.
FLOOR SESSION UPON CALL OF THE
SPEAKER.
WEDNESDAY JANUARY THIRTY FIRST
CHECK IN SESSION FLOOR SESSION
UPON CALL THE SPEAKER. THURSDAY
FEBRUARY FIRST FLOOR SESSION IS
AT NINE AM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED TO RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER COOLEY MOVES HIM AS BAKER
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED.
UNTIL THURSDAY.
FEBRUARY FIRST.
AT.
NINE A. M..
QUORUM CALLS LIFTED